rusty tuba she stops at a certain point
of your nutsack why because you have
distinct attended animals but listen no
worries you don't need to go to a
psychotherapist or a psychiatrist you
need
hellotushy.com that's what you need
you're saying joey what is that a
portable device that washes your [ __ ]
spotless clean go to hellotushy.com and
press in church and get 10 percent off
this podcast is also brought to you by
the best
lift
class you understand me when they pick
you up they got the light in front
everybody knows who you are everybody
knows who they are
lyft is a ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
all right so do me a favor if you're
considering ride sharing go to lyft.com
joey today and get a 500
new driver bonus
that's lyft.com joey
and we're going to give you a 500 new
driver bonus because lyft is the way to
go i know you're looking for work
i know you're sitting there like i'm on
a look at ya going what am i gonna do
with my life well in the meantime
before guns n roses picks you up on tour
and all that dream you got you gotta
make cash
and lyft got a job for you
lyft.com
i got a job for you all right plus you
get your own tips so at the end of the
night bam there you are you can go to
7-eleven and get a pizza or some chicken
wings you know what i'm saying left.com
press in church and get a 500 bonus
restrictions to apply hit it lisa yet
oh [ __ ]
just when you [ __ ] thought it was
safe [ __ ]
the bunny is dead the koreans [ __ ] up
but you got the church [ __ ]
monday
april 17th
[Music]
oh [ __ ] there you go
[Music]
oh yeah there we go
here we go
the church of what's happening now
what's up
lee syed my main girl
kate quigley in the [ __ ] house here
what's up talking about bringing [ __ ]
tuts into the office
next thing you notice you have a bikini
on i got a cape
i wouldn't let you do it i would do it
and you would do the weed and the acid
and the things that you bring that's so
good listen the answer is one of those
things you have to do on like a uh
say qua que qua type of nights
what does that mean i don't know what
the [ __ ] it's getting quicker
yeah it's gotta be like one of those
nights when you least expect you're
feeling down
you don't know what your next move is
and you go uncle joey you know what
tonight's the night break out of the
[ __ ] sugar cube
how much is it like the mushrooms
because i've never done acid i've only
done the mushrooms here it's in the same
neighborhood
you might see a few things it's like
when you're getting into a city and the
night like the neighborhood's nice at
the beginning but the further you drive
down the street it gets a little scary
scarier yeah that's how the mushrooms
work give you a little drop not a big
drop we'll give you a little drop to get
the party started
and just check it out from there little
drop for my size and my size is your
full size it's your first time we can we
can't give you half the bottle me and
leo do [ __ ] two drops of peace
tonight i was going to say that way i'm
feeling i got radio at 8 00 am tomorrow
do you really hear oh for the weekend
inventory yeah it's going to be fun i
love that club have you been there yet
no no it's my first time i love it it's
my favorite man i fell in love with
levity live in oxford
i haven't done that yeah
that that was a cool [ __ ] joint
sometimes you want to be on the east
coast but you don't really want to be in
the east coast that's the rule
that's true that's the best nobody knows
that you're there
you could kill somebody 80 times perfect
and they can't find your knife
you got access to the bronx white plains
you could zip it out you get fresh bread
you go to the avenue well where else can
you get that you'll be right back in
niacc before nobody knows you're missing
you know what i'm saying he's already
thought out the whole life plan and now
i just saw the people that were coming
and i'd ask him how far are you they
were going from the bronx really and you
thought these look like people it was
like three hours could kill somebody
american irish people you know i want a
couple ricans couple dominicans just
nice people i love these crazy yeah yeah
you belong in east coast with a [ __ ]
sugar cube lee what's up with you you
[ __ ] savage of death i had a great
week i said i said cleo from the
netherlands for the second time
you went to vegas you lost 20 bucks i
won 20 bucks guys
what's cleo from the netherlands she's
uh
[ __ ] savage oh and we i met her and
lady jay showed up lady jay
stan very nice dan and his wife invited
us into their house it was great larry
of course
uh
it was f i love vegas i don't know i've
said it eight thousand times i love
everything about vegas good i love vegas
that's great i like vegas too
you're queen of vegas you like marilyn
monroe
you walk around people like your
cigarettes they give you free hotel
rooms no no no cameras on the rooms they
give those rooms for free yeah i get the
rooms with the cameras and then you give
me a [ __ ] camera ten years from now
you go on the honeymoon with your
husband there you are with a dildo up
your ass with jen cheering you on thank
you joey going what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] i thought you were a great girl i
am honey that's a double how much money
did aaron andrews get if i were you i'd
be hoping for that and andre's got like
hundreds of millions i do think about
that sometimes i do think about i'm like
maybe i just have a sex tape just on
back like on the you know back burner
just in case if everything totally tanks
out then i have someone like lee kit
listen man i was always
more on the criminal side right i was
always more of a cro
i wasn't a good looking dude and i
didn't have a game
to play game
you know what i'm saying
but
when i was in the seventh grade
i got so heartbroken at every angle of
love
that i knew that if i ever had a
girlfriend
i would never do those things like i
still remember i was breaking up
i still remember a year later when she
started dating a guy how it bothered me
do you know what i'm saying
i jumped out a window yeah that you stop
so you also have to respect people's
like i remember the first time there was
a hot girl in my high school
and i used to like look at and fantasize
but go nah and i heard she was a little
loose when we were growing up like if
you gave a few [ __ ] bees
[ __ ] could crack a laugh
at that time i was like still awkwardly
sex wise so i thought it would be an
easy pick
and i got a [ __ ] buddy of mine came
up to me one night this girl she goes
can i talk to you for a second on the
side
what do you think of such and such
and like i think such and such is great
she goes what do you think if
you and her and me and your buddy double
dated downtown and i go
you're [ __ ] crazy the girl i'm
talking about in question here dates a
gorilla
i was like a [ __ ] sophomore and this
kid was like a senior but he was a
gorilla he's a good-looking big dude a
football player i thought about it i
went up to him in the hallways and i
said hey man i'll tell you something
i'm thinking of taking her out of the
date on a double date you said that to
her gorilla boyfriend the x they had
broken they haven't broken up about
three or four weeks wow that takes balls
at that age i remember you have to go up
to people and be respectful you have to
be respectful of people's feelings and
see where they're at you're such a good
guy if the guy looks at you don't get me
wrong no matter what he said i was still
gonna try to get my dick up
i was just doing it you know what i'm
saying i have a cover yeah sometimes
you're gonna have a cover sometimes you
have to have a couple why would i do
that i came to you two weeks ago we
didn't do nothing
it's not about really respect that's
more about saving yourself it was an
hysterical situation with it because
we're still dear friends today shut up
so did you ask her out
what happened was a week before it was a
a week before my mom died we were at a
halloween party i was dressed up as a
ghost
and she was a dirty witch or something
and she was at a different party
but like i said to you this chick was a
little on the loose side
and that night i went with a girl this
is a [ __ ] up story that i don't tell a
lot of people i'm at this party
and this hot blonde shows up who's my
friend on facebook so they bang it when
she was in high school she was to the
level when she was a sophomore she was
already dating men like it was
established don't even look at her yeah
she was already dating like this hot
college guy top shelf
that
so she comes up to me she goes you
didn't hook up with my friend we're all
excited you're going to hook up with her
come on i'll take you to her
so she dates a gorilla in real life so
as we're coming now to get down from
this party it was a poll how does this
happen this never worked like a [ __ ]
pole night down from the party there's a
pole this is a tremendous halloween
party fire station everybody's on acid
everybody's tripping their balls off
me and this girl walk out she's holding
my hand she's drunk pulling me what do
you think pulls up
her gorilla boyfriend oh [ __ ] and he
gets out he's going what the [ __ ] is
going on i dropped her hand and i knew
him
i knew him because he delivered beer on
the weekends and [ __ ] and we used to tip
him heavy when we were under age
so he's like what's going on here and
then he went up to her and he's like i
thought you were going in he goes i am
i'm here i'm just going to take him to
me what's her name and he started
yelling at her and i asked him i said
listen man
it's the truth i'm sorry if i
disrespected you she was a and he was
out there with you later and i go listen
please it's not her fault it's between
me and you she was just going to walk me
over there
are you still in the ghost suit i'm
still on the go so all you can see is
your eyes she gets in the car with her i
never team up with that girl but that
monday or tuesday he pulled up to me
and he goes what you did the other night
had balls you were friends now and [ __ ]
he goes she told me the whole story the
next day that you were going to hook up
with her because i'm happy for you she
had hooked up with another guy
this girl hooked up with a different
dude
so this went on for years like we never
really hooked up
and then after high school
me and this girl ended up in the same
clique
oh in college
well afterwards after high school
she was in travel age in school
[Laughter]
got it i got it and i was a [ __ ]
floater
i was just you know picking up whatever
i could you guys never did hook up no i
went to colorado and that's when we
started talking on the phone she was
having problems with her boyfriend the
boyfriend was a piece of [ __ ] meanwhile
i'm hearing reports she's blowing this
one she's blowing that one right
it's a [ __ ] nightmare
where do you get your
no because we all hung out in the same
circle
so there's a lot of gossip was she
really loose in high school did she just
have big boobs because i think she was
[ __ ] loose you knew for sure freshman
year yeah isn't that real frustrating
when you know she's banging everybody
but you never get it yes no no i wasn't
i wasn't i wasn't frustrated at that
point i just took it for what it was
then one night i went down to shore when
i was like a senior going into senior
year
and they were in this whole they were in
this apartment
and i didn't know they were there i just
went in there with some buddies of mine
were talking and was snorting coke and
those days were eating black beauties
those little speed pills they were like
speed diet pills i used to get a
thousand of them for 35 hours and sell
them for a dollar a piece bang
bang right so i went down to this party
with snort and black beauties were
drinking out of zed and [ __ ] and me and
her ended up in this bed
we walked to this bedroom and we both
now at this time she's dating a [ __ ]
super gorilla
the only thing i've got in my corner
is that i grew up with this [ __ ]
gorilla oh shoot this guy
and this guy's shooting blowing arrows
at people from his window sure this guy
was a hunter he was crazy but really
good looking and by this time he knew
she had [ __ ] 20 guys they because he
was [ __ ] chicks so she was [ __ ]
dude she didn't play games the first
words she got that you [ __ ] somebody
she was in the city swallowing an 80
steak but on the way back she'd suck
your dick like it was never never land
hysterical
i come back from colorado and i know
what time it is she's still with the
dude she's still blowing a friend of
mine
and she's [ __ ] another guy half and
half oh i come into the picture and i
start talking to her talking to her
talking to she's talking to me
and one night we hook up
we hook up and uh little little things
happen but i'll never forget one of the
things that happened
i said let me ask you a question
like the first time we really officially
got together like we had been together
before at parties and we had talked
about doing things but it always we
always went to the diner and there was
eight people there got it you know what
i'm saying it was like you were ready
to finger someone at the diner
not impossible so now we're in a con
we go to the city we have a couple of
drinks we do a couple blasts
in those days i used to get like a half
a gram of coke
like i could do a half a gram even
though i haven't done coke in 10 years i
could do a gram in one line now like
still like that's what a half i was
doing a half a gram and i forget i put
it in this mirror it was like three in
the morning
you know her ex-boyfriend was gone he
was dating somebody else it was me and
her until the end it was like a bon jovi
song you know what i'm saying yeah we
were going to run away together the
moonlight was in the mirror and i never
forgot i said to her
you know i suck my dick
and she goes i don't want to do that i
don't do that
and i'm going to look at this straight
in the face and go
what's it going to take me to suck my
dick she looked me straight in the
videos a line of coke
i gave her that line that's it that was
it we were boyfriend and girlfriend
after that was official like i fell in
love like that was it like this this was
it for real oh yeah i liked her we i had
a crush on her for four or five years oh
i used to play freshman basketball
romantic and then she snorted coke and
gave her to you i used to see her
running track jumping the high hurdles
no oh my [ __ ] she used to run like
she ran with four girls
that were as good-looking as they were
dangerous
like i'll tell you how good her crew was
in high school it's a cool company when
they were sophomores and juniors one of
them dated
we used to see him in mars
in fact she's the girl that is here now
matt dylan
no way when i was in high school one of
that serious from robert the robert
fulton crew yeah they used to because
her brother was named colombia
so she used to call the columbia sister
but columbia's sister used to have like
when we used to walk up from the park
and there'd be the porsche
and we'd go to merex and there'd be matt
dylan with colombia's sister damn
mugging it up at the corner that's how
badass those [ __ ] were yeah there was
twins
there were these two italian twins that
were [ __ ] sensational their asses
there was the girl i was in love with
the redhead yeah there was the [ __ ]
uh there was a blonde that was banging
and these are these girls already had
reputations
as sophomores and two basketball players
and taking them home and they did a
threesome like these girls were done
done but they were banging they all had
boyfriends so here's me and [ __ ] the
redhead
was trying to sneak around this [ __ ]
this is no lie and i'm living maybe a
block and a half from it
so basically i'm going our house at
night and going in her back window and
not her back went to her back door and i
would go in the living room and her
parents would always stay upstairs they
were told no ever come down that's the
best it's hysterical sneaking in though
that is the best i would go in here we'd
have sex and i'd leave and walk out
anyway
one sunday
i call her up
what do you want to do now i'm broke lee
i'm making 250 a week
so if i take it to a hotel i got a
[ __ ] baby as
that's a lot of money in high school
1983 no we're out of high school now
okay cool about a year or two out of
high school i'm making about 250 a week
working 40 hours [ __ ] stock and pipe
and electrical supplies so when i spent
60 dollars on a piece of [ __ ] it had to
be [ __ ] primavera like i was going to
stab you eat your ass eat one of these
eyeballs
it was on like if we did blow you it was
it was going to be a 12 hour marathon i
was gonna eat your [ __ ] while you're
sleeping don't worry just keep sleeping
i gotta get the 60 miles out of this
cocaine keep sleeping [ __ ] horrible
[ __ ] that i want to be awake for that
one sunday night we go into the city
and we go [ __ ] it let's get high and we
get eight valiums for ten dollars
how much was it no
by washington square park
in those days on sundays dave chappelle
would perform with this black comedian i
forget his name now
he was maybe 14.
oh wow so the hip thing to do in those
days like if you had a boyfriend
well so everybody else was eating pasta
at the house you and me were going to
the city and about four cats the tail
end of dave chappelle and the southern
charlie brown charlie barnett and we'd
go to
there was a mcsorley's hell no and i
know i'm [ __ ] up the name right in
the village right there and you're going
to get three mugs for like four bucks
and a bowl of chili
while you were eating mama i'd go over
and get ten valium eight valiants and a
[ __ ] bag of reefer
and we'd each pop like a little valium
we'd smoke some tootsie roots you'd get
lu that was young love yeah kate
quigley's young lover
i mean we're holding hands
we're creeping around new york we're
listening to bon no bon jovi wasn't even
out yet no none of that [ __ ] it was just
in your mind never say goodbye
never said like we were into it so we
both went back to our respected houses
we she went home to dinner i went home
to dinner at the lorenzos
and that night we go let's go to a hotel
okay so she goes i'll pick you up at
eight or you could walk to the york
motel the york motel was at walking
distance
you could go in there with no id it
smelled like it smelled like sperm there
were clean towels you could smell that
you could smell the hindu family
but you know what who gives a [ __ ] when
you just when you're young and you want
to have sex you don't even look at those
things young i did that like six months
ago
who cares so we go down now she's dating
now this gorilla we haven't heard from
him
in like three weeks we're running around
town like [ __ ]
sean penn and madonna you know but this
gorilla has not shown his [ __ ] face
so finally at 8 15 that night she picks
me up
and she goes i don't want to worry you
but he's been calling the house all
night
and he's pissed off he says he wants to
get back with me that he misses me and
he loves me i go listen you do whatever
you got to do let's go to the hotel
first
you know what i'm saying like i didn't
give a [ __ ]
i didn't give a [ __ ]
we have sex for three hours i eat the
rest
it's the best the first time we go to
carvel we get ice cream like young
lovers yeah you know and then we're
going up the hill we're stopped at a
light who do you think
jumps on the hood oh
no he jumped on the hood are you
really jumped on and held down like yeah
yes he did yes he did he just know where
you were he was looking for her walking
around the neighborhood oh my god he's
holding on to the windshield he's like
you
get out of the car lisa i want to talk
to you
so i [ __ ] get out of the car and i go
what's up dog and he goes where the [ __ ]
are you guys coming from you answer me
first like we went to the [ __ ] movies
and we we already had an excuse we
dropped off lee
at home we all went to chan's dragging
in that's why i got beat up meanwhile
meanwhile he goes well coco can you walk
home can i talk to my girlfriend and i
go you do whatever you want she's like
no i don't want to talk to him i'm like
jesus [ __ ] christ i'm not taking her
and she's like no i don't want to talk
to you i told you already you cheated on
me you suck and all this [ __ ] i'm
standing there and meanwhile
he goes wait a second why is your shirt
on backwards i knew you were going oh my
god
a [ __ ] label was out oh my god he
goes were you in a rush or something
coco didn't you say something to her i'm
like no i'm high i didn't see it
like i picked her up at the gym i don't
know what happened it was [ __ ] crazy
i can't believe you got out of the car
if a dude jumped on the hood of my car
there's no way i'm getting out i would
just i would back up drive with you i
throw it in reverse yeah i grew up with
him
still i mean we weren't doing nothing we
looked innocent in the car there was no
alcohol that's what i would do i would
jump right if someone jumped on my hood
um
he's a gorilla he's huge and you just
[ __ ] it listen to me so listen to me
the guy before me
was [ __ ] uh and he would actually
torment the kid
okay the guy
yeah in fact the guy's brother listens
to this podcast religiously shut up he's
gonna laugh
the brother never had a girlfriend this
chick
used to suck his dick and he'd go crazy
i mean he fell in love with her he went
crazy so one night there at a bar this
was going on for like like if if if the
gorilla was in the bar
and my friend who was now [ __ ] his
girlfriend was now they were together at
the time yeah and she was [ __ ] my
friend
my friend would actually go to a bar buy
him a drink
and send it over and drink it and then
he'd walk out so the attention was going
on wow so now it's a wednesday night
it's ladies night at this bar off timely
boulevard yeah and we're all in there
we're [ __ ] having a good time
and boom gorilla man walks in with the
broad
now two hours earlier she was blowing my
friend i mean it was an ugly ugly thing
[ __ ] we're all sitting there
and gorilla man sends him a drink with
love
like keep sending them drinks with
[ __ ] love did he know like oh yeah
everybody knew everybody knew the guy
every 80 people in that bar knew what
was going on oh my god and here's my
buddy
sending gorilla mcgillin's gorilla
drinks
going like that's on me she's beautiful
i love her and this was heating up and
they fought for like two minutes
and then he clipped me one night too for
one this one on but same thing i thought
i was in love with it too well he kind
of worked he i saw his hand come over
and i just fell to the floor and i
didn't say a word after that he punched
you just for liking her he didn't even
you guys weren't even talking
by this time we had 69
the liking was over we were going away
for the weekend
how can this chick do that i get
stressed out if i even date two guys
that know each other we were together
for like six weeks then this [ __ ] just
broke apart and then after that we had
sex a few more times and
you know
you know what the real true story is
that
i can't remember if somebody would do
that to me
thinking back i would never talk to her
you know what happened here her and i
were good friends
ah
you know what man we wanted to we were
young if we would have bumped into each
other we were 24
we would never have done that
there was cocaine involved mm-hmm she
was a part-time she was a part-time
hooker you know she was she was not no
she was a part-time [ __ ] she liked it
she well um
if you're [ __ ] a bunch of dudes that
all know each other you're kind of
getting off on that attention you have
to be she was beautiful she was and you
know what man until today she's one of
my best best
best friends in life i heard even before
listen
i have a my daughter's godfather told me
he was at a party 20 years ago
and somebody brought my name up and
people like [ __ ] that dude i hope he
burns in hell she's like listen [ __ ]
i will [ __ ] yous all up i love it
she's like he's doing comedy i think
he's inside the time i was in seattle
and then like he'll never do nothing
with his life and she was like you guys
you guys got something good and she's
been there
she's married i love her husband today
you know i mean the last embarrassment
and i thought about this the other day i
was at a christmas party coked up to the
gills
and she was there
with the dude she was dating now
but she's just broken up with a dude
magilla gorilla was there
really i was there did you still see
this gorilla guy everyone no no so i
didn't see him no i'm lying to you i
didn't see him at that party but that
night i got really drunk and i had her
in the bathroom and i remember telling
how much i loved her and she's going you
know i kind of like this guy and all
this and we can't do this like all right
don't worry about none just some suck my
dick
that's all i wanted and she's like no
absolutely not guys are always like just
one more time
and she ran out of there
and then i did something new year's eve
i beat this guy for drugs
on new year's eve for like three
thousand dollars and i started a new
life in crescal new jersey
okay and i'm in crescal three weeks i
get a job at the liquor store
i'm going into manhattan every day i'm
looking for work i'm buying nickel bags
of wheat i'm off the coke
and i'm walking past the church one day
it was about dinner time a church a
church and you thought i should start a
podcast just just any regular church and
i look in
and i'm looking at the elevator
and it's mcgill gorilla
he was a union elevator guy like that's
what he did in high school he
apprenticed
with his family and a bunch of other
kids from my area they became elevator
mechanics and i saw him and i go and it
was january of 85
and the last time we had you know me and
him had grown up together i mean him and
i robbed a van him and i played football
together as a kid we played basketball
we we gave people nicknames we we smoked
dope together we we robbed a van we oh
they left the van on the side of the
street with t-shirts and and stickers
and glue presses so what we did is we we
[ __ ] stole everything
and we took it out and then we go all
into the van we gotta do something with
the van i mean it was [ __ ] crazy but
i walked up to him he walked up to me i
put my hand down they go i'm sorry bro
about that whole thing and he put out
his hand and he goes can you imagine
like we all acted this [ __ ] like we both
could not believe what had happened
like i wasn't mad at that i was never
mad at that girl in fact
i went to prison came out
and i was in the halfway house and my
friends came out from
jersey and we were talking and one of
them pulled me aside and i was listening
bro
i bumped into your body about a week ago
and i told her i was coming out here to
see
she she said before you get married make
sure you give her a call
it was weird like i'm not calling him
like that how can i trust her you know
i'm sorry i'm like she's got [ __ ] 19
sperms
different [ __ ] friends of mine you
think that's why she wanted to talk like
before she no you know who knew what she
wanted but by that point i had already
made a bad decision with the wife i was
picking
i had already had a [ __ ] life why
would i start a new life you know it's
just weird how things worked out but now
at 54 i will tell you she's
one of my biggest like when i go home i
meet at a chinese place i know her
mother i know her father oh i left my
album collection to her sister her
sister was a heavy metal chick who liked
music
i shoplifted all those albums anyway it
was like 400 [ __ ] albums i'd give her
a milk crate no way yeah that's so
awesome
it's amazing to have friends like that
that your friends your whole life well
we're done we're done so [ __ ] in the end
lucky you have that i don't think many
people still know people that they went
to high school with i mean i i can count
on no i know two people i went to high
school with one i have one but i was
gonna ask kate
is it
is it hard being like a girl who likes
to have sex like nobody no uh it's not
hard
it just seemed because it like
the whole time joe was telling that
story all i was thinking about was i've
never once and i i just didn't have sex
with many people but i never once even
dated anyone that a friend dated it
would seem too weird i didn't want to
kiss anybody that someone else had
kissed i knew yeah so just i have had
that problem because i've dated a few
well like i've dated
uh this is a small industry like
hollywood even though it's a big town
you know it's kind of like high school
everybody knows everybody so if you hook
up with one comic or one actor one
person in the business then i feel like
everybody else in the business that you
meet might be kind of pals with that
person or know that person and then yeah
i had a guy say to me that i was really
into he's like i can't date you because
i know too much like because i had
[ __ ] guys that he knew he couldn't he
wouldn't date me just because of that so
yeah it kind of it's hard for people
some people can't get up
i don't care though i believe that you
have to get over things
you know you you if you date a chick
that's on youtube and six midgets are
coming out of the face
you have to decide whether you want her
to be the mother of your child it's hard
to find on youtube yeah that's tough to
find you know what i'm saying that's on
pornhub not youtube you decide like i i
did this thing with sam tripoli and
a bunch of guys maybe in the year 2000
about a porno thing
some guy had in his mind he wanted to do
what
that dude did and have porno you know
the chicks would come to your party what
was that show the guy went the [ __ ]
jail he hung out with the kardashians
and [ __ ]
the guy had video girls girls gone wild
yeah and this [ __ ] genius i wanted to
put together in a beverly hills mansion
200 chicks and
you know a bunch of [ __ ] loser guys
with cologne on and me tripoli and who's
the other guy come on tebow
a bunch of us ari we all did comedy at
this porno thing and if it made money
we'd get a percentage of it
was one of the worst things you've ever
seen in your life but
i wish i was there the one thing i took
out of that party was that i had heard
about but i had never seen and it
disgusted me was a guy who was there
he was married to abroad that was really
like a seven
but he brought him there to get [ __ ]
by ten guys at this party no way yeah
and he's standing there while these guys
are [ __ ] his wife in the back room
some guys are into that
it's so weird to me but some guys are
into that like i i dated a guy it was
like a long distance thing and he one
time said to me that he wanted to watch
me [ __ ] another guy on
facetime did you do it no i was like so
offended it changed everything i was
like how can you want to see me [ __ ]
someone else it really bothered me i
would never
i dated a porn actor so i've had to
watch a guy i liked [ __ ] other people i
don't like it it's not it's not fun
would you want to watch your girl [ __ ]
somebody else hell no not really not
really not really
but wait can i tell you
my best like redemption story from my
dating i haven't told this anywhere
you're this this story is amazing well
you heard it here first okay so i was
dating this guy and i was like hung up i
told you about this guy that i was kind
of seeing he was a porn actor it was
such a bad move but i was like really
hung up we dated for a while like six
seven months and then we stopped talking
because i this is so [ __ ] up i wanted
more like i wanted like it to be a
relationship i don't know why because
he's a poor next i'm not
i'm not making wise life choices in my
love life uh but neither is lee so it's
no i'm not
wait
was he the best sex you ever had
the best sex i mean that's the problem
he was not a good guy like from jump he
was a dick but
he was the sex once we [ __ ] i said i
wouldn't date him and then we hung out a
few times and then we had sex and then i
was like i want a relationship like the
sex was mind-blowing
do you do viagra ever no i mean like
it's just that he couldn't [ __ ] for so
long like for hours and
i never came up it doesn't matter i
don't want this to go to his head if he
ever hears this so the sex was just fine
okay so anyway then uh i wanted more and
he didn't so we stopped talking let me
ask you something on the legit side yeah
why you're falling in love when you're
sucking that pipe let's not call it love
i don't think it was love joey okay
it was more like i was dignitized i was
just hypnotized by the dick the dick was
good i never had such a good dick before
and on the legitimacy he would beat me
up and he would like he would like call
me names hold on hold on before you
start making accusations
let me ask you a question on the oven up
here let's pretend you're sucking this
pipe right okay don't you think that he
had done up some arabian's ass on
tuesday yeah porn scene and you're
sucking like here's what happened i
decided to to block it out mentally
because when we would hang out he would
never talk about porn he would talk
about other things he was into like what
what else could he possibly be into like
he was into like cars and like um
crossfit
[Applause]
but fighting like other things you know
so we just wouldn't talk about porn and
i would just i unfollowed him on
everything so i would never see the porn
so i just i just put it out of my head
even though i knew but also he was
always like i'm gonna stop doing it soon
so i was like okay
and i thought think about it i thought
it would be a great relationship because
i was like this is a guy who will not be
chasing [ __ ] because he gets so much
[ __ ] so he'll be just happy enough with
the porn [ __ ] and me
right so that was the plan
that was that was my plan but it didn't
work because it turned out when i said
hey what do you think if we make this
like a relationship
he was like oh no i still want to [ __ ]
other people and i was like but you get
to [ __ ] like 50 girls a week and he was
like i want to also [ __ ] other people so
we stopped talking okay so three months
goes by
no talking
and then it's my fault one night i got a
little drunk and i texted him and i said
hi
just hi
and then he texts back hey
and then i said i've been thinking about
you
and then he said i've been thinking
about you too and i said what have you
been thinking about and then he's like
you know i've been thinking about
the fights but then i've also been
thinking about like beating your ass and
like [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you and all
this stuff right
and then i like a typical girl i go
well um do you miss more than just
[ __ ] me or is it pretty much just the
sex
and then he was like no i really miss
you
so then i'm like oh so then i'm like
what are you doing tonight why don't i
come over and he's like yeah come over
so i go to his house it's like 1am
we [ __ ] okay
3 a.m
he's like we're cuddling and he goes hey
so um you don't get to stay the night
you probably should take off
and i was like what what are you talking
about it's three o'clock in the morning
and he goes well you haven't earned your
way into sleeping over yet i haven't
seen you in a while
so i was like
all right oh lord so i left it sounds
like the dirtier version to the start of
bridesmaids
like that just that's the same
bridesmaids this is reality but this is
where it gets good okay
i wake up the next day
i'm pissed as [ __ ] i'm so mad that he
threw me out it's like i woke up in the
morning sober and i'm like did that
really happen that [ __ ] kicked
me out at 3am so then i start texting
him joey i was a psychopath i sent him
like 45 text messages every time he
wouldn't answer i text him again and
again and again and again and i kept
asking him why he kicked me out and
finally he wrote back and told me that
he didn't want me to have feelings for
him because he found out he's having a
kid with another girl so he didn't want
to date me so that's why he asked me to
leave so then i was like but you said
that you missed me and he's like well i
did but i really just wanted to [ __ ] and
you know i was it was late and that was
that so
i'm pissed as [ __ ] then i start going
off on him with text he blocks my number
so then i'm a psycho so i found an app
where you can text from like 45
different phone numbers and i started
sending them texts from all these
different phone numbers like i was so
angry
but it became funny so i started
pretending to be other people and like
really [ __ ] with them and and i'm a
crazy person
but here's the thing the next day i go
on my podcast
and i tell the story
and i don't think anything of it i just
tell it i'm angry and i don't say who he
is but i tell the story
my phone rings a few hours after the
podcast comes out and it's him and he's
freaking out and telling me that i
ruined his life
because it turns out
he has a girlfriend and she listens to
my podcast she's like a fan of mine and
she loves my podcast and she put
together from the story that i was
talking about him and she didn't know he
was having a kid with another girl so
now
i ruined his relationship because it
turns out he has a girlfriend and he has
a baby mom and he had me he had this
whole love triangle
and i didn't know
the point is i feel i feel i'm angry i'm
angry right now i'm just tired of
getting [ __ ] over why don't you start
dating lee listen
he ain't gonna cheat on you he'll bring
home gravy every week how amazing how
amazing you'll give your ride to the gig
your manager he'll manage your career i
need a guy like lee
lee would treat me well unbelievable how
crazy is it though what are the odds
that this random girl listens to my
podcast and figured it out you lick
lee's nut sack
joey he'll give you the combination to
his mother's safe understand you don't
give a [ __ ] that's what the jew jewels
are tell you and the picture of [ __ ]
lee next to hitler
but here's how like psychotic i realized
this is how i realized i need therapy
because i actually i called my lawyer to
ask my lawyer what the boundaries are of
like [ __ ] with someone after they
hurt you so then i had made my lawyer
write me a whole letter of all the
things i'm allowed to do to [ __ ] with
someone so you just explained to me why
you're single
[Laughter]
because you're [ __ ] nuts i love it i
know i am but i'm in love with
he's lucky i liked him it wasn't love it
was just
lust it was exactly free and yes sex
now what's this with you gotta beat you
up you like getting smacked around a
little bit yeah every girl does i'm
punched to the head
not like a punch to the head like mma
style but a little like a little slappy
little slap me to the stomach i do no no
no no whip your ass grab you by the neck
and tell you to suck my dick you dirty
filthy [ __ ] animal every girl likes
that i think and then take the dick out
of your mouth and hit you in the face
and shove it right back in your mouth
like a savage joey that's that's that's
perfect that's what every girl your arms
are to the side like yeah yeah you're
like chinese chick that's like well they
call them when they put them in there
when they're bound no they put them in
the bottom of a trunk what do they call
them what
oh he's talking about the
the sex lames like
they put their hands in trunks right
they just put them at you like maybe you
don't know what's going on when they
take the dick out of your mouth and hit
you in the face four times they put it
back in there
and you have your hands yeah that's
tremendous all that stuff okay i don't
know about it i love you i love all that
[ __ ] trust me i do i like every i have a
theory that every girl likes [ __ ]
yeah and call you a filthy you want to
be treated respectfully out you know in
public but
i let one guy one time absolutely so
you're the real deal but i really like
loved him we were like together
but i'm not into that i'm not into being
peed on at what point in the
relationship did he bring up that he
wanted to be
actually no it's funny i've realized
with guys it seems i've only been in a
couple relationships that around the six
month point is when they start to tell
you about like weird [ __ ] they're into
like they finally are like okay i can
tell this like that same guy
he asked me if he could pee on me he
wanted to pee on me yeah and he also
asked me to eat his butthole all right
no one ever asked he was like but the
way he asked you was like we were in bed
one night and he was like um
so
have you ever like licked a butthole
before
and i was like
no no no i haven't i can't say i've ever
it's not really my hobby in in my
wheelhouse and then he was like i just
i'm really kind of into that
and then i was like okay well i don't
mind i don't mind but like
we need to plan this out like i think
maybe you have to shower immediately
yeah i mean before you even ask you got
a shower are you guys into that dude i
always wonder how many guys are into
that listen i don't i don't go out
looking for it
my [ __ ] you know me i'm always
available i'm like denny's you don't
shut down really you know what man
i gotta be honest with you guys at least
i'm naive
i think when i was like 21-22 21
somebody sucked my balls and gave me a
hand job i thought it was tremendous
yeah and then it sounds nice
and that's where it ended when you snort
coke they would suck down there and suck
your balls hard and [ __ ] and sometimes
you'd feel a tongue
and you know like i said guys i didn't
some of the [ __ ] i was just scared of or
whatever
fast forward
to 1995 boulder colorado
i meet this girl boom on the phone
[Music]
a month later she shows up
we go camping
a little bit of sex that night nothing
serious and next two days later we go
back to my apartment
i'll never forget she looked me straight
in the face and she goes turn around
she looked you straight in the face and
said
that's amazing what are you talking
about is if she goes if you turn around
i'll eat your [ __ ] and suck your ball
sack from behind and jerk you off and
then when you come i'll drop and you
could come home it was craziness i had
never heard that type of language you
were like yes yes yes ma'am i looked the
straight in the face and go no
i knew my [ __ ] stunk but she was a
filthy animal anyway oh it was like
middle of the day like it was after like
a walk and [ __ ] oh hell no
i'm not gonna let you eat my nose then
you'll never do it again you know the
reputation
after a couple years with her i would
make her eat my ass after doing a set at
the comments no you would not yes i
would she was crazy like you yeah yeah
but i wouldn't even do that we would we
would we had a we had a straight
relationship and then we had a drug
relationship
our straight relationship was we'd get
high smoke a joint maybe have a glass of
wine and i'd [ __ ] her and we'd go to bed
our cocaine relationship she opened up
with a smack to the face
she hit you or you know i'd smack them
like three or four times
grab her and put her right on my [ __ ]
nut sack
damn then i tip her underneath
and make her eat my [ __ ] from down
below while she's jerking me off then
put my pipe in the mouth so you do like
it having your butt yeah
at that time in that situation yeah she
was the right time at the right girl but
not at any time not all the time well
that no before that
that's interesting that was what year
this all went down from 95 to about 99.
just crazy
i've had this theory that girls eating
[ __ ] is like i was dirty you were fat
i was 32
when i met her and she was 25.
wow
and she was crazy it was just crazy so
i'm not crazy
you know what i'm saying if you
volunteer
and that's what i'm saying like if
if
you're doing coke with somebody
you know that person's eating [ __ ] if
we got like an eight ball or a half
ounce of blood that's just you know yeah
it never crosses my it never causes my
mind to eat a guy's ass unless they ask
it never go i never i know that but once
you're doing blow and you're sucking my
dick and i got dead you're going okay do
me a favor lift the nut sack and massage
that ass
you'll take a shot of that tequila and
lick that [ __ ] like a savage that you
always [ __ ] that's why i love you to
death you don't give a [ __ ] you'll take
that pbp ad off you know what it is i
want to be the best at everything
including [ __ ] so like if i'm [ __ ]
a guy this is my thing i want to [ __ ]
them so good that after i'm gone for the
rest of their life they're like [ __ ]
and [ __ ] like that again like that's
what i want i want to be in the back of
their mind i want to be sealed in
burned in like a [ __ ] prison tattoo
you're [ __ ] great now what are you
gonna do when you meet your husband
the next one
no the real one the one that she's
supposed to i don't know he's right
around not really crazy i mean i was
right around the corner you think yeah
listen i'm not the truth is the truth is
i'm really i'm really not crazy i'm just
i'm i'm no no no i'm hyper sexual i like
sex but
i don't [ __ ] a lot of people i think
that's a big misconception is like
because i i talk about what do you have
is a week two dudes no i swear to god i
i counted up my number for my own
podcast the other day you know what i'm
up to it's not even that high 17 for the
year total ever
that's it get the [ __ ] out i swear to
god i counted them how many things have
you sucked
that i didn't have sex with yeah not
many no not many because like i'm that
girl that like once we're making out see
that's the thing i don't make out with a
lot of guys the number of guys i've made
out with is probably not much higher no
there's no reason to make that usually
if we start making out in my mind i'm
like okay so then date three we [ __ ]
like there's no guys i like test make
out do you know what i mean i'm not
making that cake going away it's turning
around no i do make out for a few dates
i make out i mean
i don't want to hear your stories turn
around drop those pants i see that i do
make out for the first few dates and
then after that what i'm saying is i
don't make out with guys i know i'm not
gonna [ __ ] if i know in my mind like if
we kiss and it's good it's gonna get
there eventually do you know what i mean
oh yeah yeah i don't kiss guys unless
i'm really kissily right
now
you should have seen lee's face when i
said that
yeah gotta send my heart attack
you're gonna say how to set my heart on
i'm like thank you no that too it went
up and it went right down
he thought about the consequences of
[ __ ] he's a married manly he's
practically married he's a man he's a
decent man he's a good guy so are you
that's a thing you're a good guy see i
meet these great guys like you and i
think to myself they're here they're
just and i know like i really do want to
meet a good guy but i don't want to get
married i have no interest in getting
married again
what about i turned you off
um nothing i'm not against marriage i
just for me like
i don't need it like i don't need the
ring in the piece of paper like if i'm
with someone if i meet a guy and i'm
that's why my number's low because when
i meet a guy and i like him
i kind of stop [ __ ] other people not
on purpose i just when i'm when i like
someone i don't really look around for
other guys i know you're supposed to
keep a little rotation that's what i'm
trying to get better at trying to
date a couple at once but it's hard
because once i like one i start to kind
of ignore everyone else i never really
liked promiscuous chicks
at a young age i always avoided them
but now unless
it was mandatory you know what i'm
saying like no but i really didn't i
really did avoid them
just because of a fear
and a buddy of mine i had to go into a
clinic one time and i saw a guy with a
rash and just
it was a combination of things it was
like catholicism
and all that stuff you know and i have
some of that too
when i hooked up with that
check and i left new jersey
like
i wasn't i was
22 years old and i knew
what my mission was
and at the time i really wasn't looking
for a woman
like it wasn't even in my itinerary at
22 what was your mission
my itinerary was to
find what i loved try to get back into
college
and get my life together yeah the woman
was not even yeah in the [ __ ] horizon
see that's kind of the opposite i was
like that's how i am now like when i was
young i thought because i'm from ohio it
was like find a husband find a man find
a man that that was kind of it now i
feel like how you did then like but
here's the crazy thing
not that
they weren't in the horizon
because of that reason i'll tell you why
the truth was
because of what this girl had done to me
i was raised that you know what okay
i'm an old school type of dude
so when you come [ __ ] with me
you're gonna [ __ ] with me like i was
watching that the other night i was
watching the dumbest movie in the world
my wife and i went out to dinner and we
were tired and she went into bed first
with the baby and i stayed down
and i was watching hbo they had the
hector level
moving on
what movie
no no no it's uh hbo movie that they did
as a matter of fact while i was shooting
along this yard the wardrobe check gave
me the script because she works with
jennifer lopez and she goes read this
and if you like a role in that there was
really nothing for me
but they shot this movie and they made
it about jennifer lopez but it was about
a singer
and the first time he met her he was on
stage
and he found out that it was her
birthday
and he went to her house
on her birthday we're having a puerto
rican party
it's 1970 in new york city in the bronx
and
it's just a regular puerto rican family
on saturday night food
the neighbors your girls from the hood
and he walks in there and they're
dancing and [ __ ] and he's a regular nerd
hector level
and
he's talking to the girl and finally the
guy comes over her brother and he grabs
her
and he goes i have some friendly
brotherly advice for you
if you're gonna [ __ ] with her
you better [ __ ] with her
do you understand me and it took me back
for a second i was like
that was always my mentality i like that
if i take kate and i busted cherry
and once she sucks my dick and i ate a
[ __ ] cape belongs to me
like it was that time i liked that like
it was like you were my woman for life
that's how i was raised i like that
that's how i was raised to be honest
with you that was what i was led to
believe
so for life is long but no so when i got
let me tell you something that that down
my [ __ ] saddles
so when i hooked up with my first wife
and that [ __ ] went down
i was done
i was on i was on a cake quigley i was
on a seek
and destroyed [ __ ] and [ __ ] tour
you know and that's when i started
comedy yeah and i took comedy for what
it was you know you go to a strange town
i have a boyfriend but he's works from
four to twelve but he works from four to
six in the morning but i could get you a
gram of coke
let's take a look
at the next thing when you're in the
hotel next thing you know we're 69 and
next thing i'm coming in you and next
thing you know you're out the door and i
was sitting there with an eight ball and
you got to go home and tell your
boyfriend you hung out and watched the
movie with me it's it was sad it was sad
the different situations i was put into
and the different lies i found out about
life because i can't put it all on women
i know what you mean yeah i can't put it
all on women it's about men too that's
what's happening to me that's what's
happening to me now i swear to god i
know this sounds so naive because i've
been out here for 10 years but i've only
been single for like four
and
it's really taken me until this year
i still had that innocent midwestern
like wholesome mentality like people
don't lie like no one's gonna lie to
[ __ ] me like everybody's being honest
like i really i know it sounds so stupid
but this is the first year i finally
realized like what's really going on
okay i dated a few guys in a row that i
found out had either a girlfriend and a
kid or a wife or another like i keep
being the side chick i am the side chick
i'm like the consummate
side chick but it never even occurs to
me like this is the first time i ever
the other day a guy asked me out it's a
true a football player he used to um i
won't give away who he is but a football
player he asked me out on a date we're
flirting we're like dm'ing and then uh
i'm like okay we made plans to get a
drink and then my friend goes you should
google him just make sure he doesn't
have a girlfriend i never google people
because i have like a rule about it
because there's so much [ __ ] online that
makes it you can get to know someone
without really getting to know them you
know so i don't google people
finally i was like [ __ ] it i'm just
gonna google this guy to make sure he's
single he's married he's married with
kids and not only married but he's on
like a reality show about like married
football players like he's publicly like
super married and i was just like this
is so sad that it's at a point in our
society where you have to ask someone
are you single
before you go out like if someone asks
you out it doesn't mean they're single
okay i'm 54 years old
i've been married for nine years i've
been with him for 18 years
whatever we're gonna do we're gonna do
you know i'm saying you stay together
because you love somebody
or whatever it's nice in your mind
lee and i were having a tremendous
conversation once we came on the show
and i don't know how he came up we were
talking about sugar daddies
and we're talking about all that [ __ ]
and i was messing around with lee one
day on the phone and we're both giggling
about
lee this is how you would do it you know
like oj killed his wife
it's the same thing i go you could
either
go out and cheat on your wife and every
time you throw spaghetti against the
wall
it's going to stick eventually or you go
to kate and go kate can i talk to you on
the side for a second i love you ken
i've always had a crush on you
i know you want to smack me in the face
i'm married listen
i'm an attorney i print money
right what if what if
what if i leased you
gsl 360. yeah i'm just making up the
names and numbers here guys what if i
put you on wilshire boulevard private
valet but here's the catch i come over
one night a month
and i like your [ __ ] i'm fine i know
girls that do that no listen yeah okay
and i was telling lee about this and he
goes you know i never i never really
thought i only you put him up in vegas
you know i stayed away from your family
if you have that type of money
the only way you listen you have to
think about this professional football
player you have to think about how sad
this is
how sad our society is that
you got three different things here that
a girl would show up and suck his dick
he's a professional for sure i'm sure
that's what he thought yeah number two
that a guy in that position
would risk everything right that's what
i thought
he doesn't even know who you want
you could be some chick that says come
in me
i'm protected that's right
or how lucky is he set him up for 40 000
a month child support and ruin his life
anyway
you kind of think about these people not
even just that how we we make our own
[ __ ] graves at the best time of our
lives this is what's going on
this is when you're the most vulnerable
see people think that when you were
doing what i was doing like when i was a
kid and i was robbing that's when you
got to watch your back no
that's the easy [ __ ]
it's when you start becoming successful
yep
and all of a sudden your wife is more
interested in the kid and a television
set and a [ __ ] game of backgammon and
also one night you go you know my
receptionist is looking good
and she was telling me about dumping the
boyfriend and then she's broke and she
needs a new car ha ha ha
ha ha nobody knows i got a paypal
account
that's busting at the scenes
waiting for a young woman to give her an
envelope
you know and you just live that life
you're going crazy though man you tell
your wife you're gonna play golf lee
yeah and twice a month you gotta get a
little southwest flight you even bring
the kids and wave at them
where you going yeah i'll be in bed
early you go to vegas you go right to
your woman's house you pick up a
portable phone with a non-tracer so even
even if they're looking for pablo they
can't find you by mistake
but what i don't get about that is why
have a whole side girl side relationship
that you're paying for instead of just
if all that if what you really want is
just to [ __ ] other people and you have
money why not hire like high class
escorts because somewhere along the line
is going to leak and then 800 a pipe
oh this is cheaper
i guess in the long run yeah it's 800
900 a thousand a pop a tip
and you're still liable that they might
say something that's what's crazy man
it's just i always said when i was
married if i got to a point where i was
gonna cheat i would just leave him and
now there's so many people there's so
many people i know who are in open
relationships like i i couldn't do an
open relationship but i would be open to
an occasional threesome
with another girl yeah
so i mean like but there's i have
friends that are in open relationships
where they let their guy occasionally
hook up with someone else and it doesn't
bother them so why why be in a
relationship where you're not getting
what you want like if you're married to
someone and what you really want is to
[ __ ] a bunch other people why not just
be single in my world i don't want to
see nobody else's [ __ ]
i don't want to see nobody else's penis
what's tony bellic toxicity especially
no one else's penis
i like that
[Music]
oh
oh [ __ ]
i feel sober
[ __ ] it
how was that weed
it was good you could take that home
with you
that's good weed sativa take it home i
don't know how to do it i don't have
them you don't want to do nothing here
we are
all right you never know how to do that
i don't want to grab it i don't know how
to grab it grab the [ __ ] thing like
like a
still in there flute whatever you want
this is kind of this is kind of a [ __ ]
up song by the way i was listening to it
today
tony bennett's like throwing [ __ ] down
yeah throw [ __ ] down that's kate
ah oh [ __ ]
no
there's a part of you that sometimes
you want to try that i never liked the
idea
i never liked the concept
i'm with you okay you're with me
anything else
it can't happen
yeah it can't happen
you know that's a great idea but
somewhere along the line
somebody's gonna get [ __ ] up here
those people do threesomes all the time
if you look at the percentages and
they're really out there somewhere when
one night you freak out
or one night i freak out
one night i'm giving a little bit more
attention to this brunette
and one night you're sucking this guy's
dick like it's the first dick you ever
sucked in your life true and your
husband sees that yeah yeah
it's always listen all that kinky [ __ ]
just
listen if
you're doing it i applaud you it's
making it work for you i just did never
work for me i'm too uptight i'm very
sorry i'm just afraid that that's the
only way to keep someone
forever and you know
listen man but here's the thing
here's the thing a relationship is just
like [ __ ] life okay
i might leave here tonight on the way
out
the people in the front thing leave that
curtain open
and then there's two kilos of coke and
60 000 cash and i kicked the door
and i take that [ __ ] and i sell the coke
and i got 120k
within six months something's gonna
happen in my life
then i'm gonna pay that 120k something's
gonna happen i'm gonna get busted with
the coke now i've got a hundred thousand
dollar bail on my attorney 120 000 and
at the end of it all i'm gonna end up
making like two thousand dollars for
what i did you pay for everything in
life true you're in a relationship
you're happy every woman's always happy
every guy is always happy so that one ex
who beat you and stole your car right
and stole your mother's [ __ ] value
and prescription
you know took your brother's gun he
calls you and also it [ __ ] with your
head for a week
and it [ __ ] with your head and here you
are with a guy or a girl that you're
[ __ ] genuinely happy with yeah they
maybe have one handicap he doesn't drink
and he snores or his feet smell but
genuinely you really want to marry this
guy or this girl
but that dumb [ __ ] or that dumbass
always calls you up after eight months
and [ __ ] up your head you're right and
you go over there you suck his dick or
you eat a [ __ ]
and at the end of it all bro two things
happen
either the thing that happened in
boomerang which is why i love boomerang
and what happens in real life or
you get to jump and you switch
governments when you know what
when you cheat on somebody to get
somebody
that's never can't do it because then
it's in their mind it's in both of your
minds
so at that point you have to decide you
know what this made me realize how much
i love that person you don't go home you
don't write yourself out
you just don't do it again did i tell
you what happened with the one threesome
that i had i had a threesome i've only
had one threesome and it wasn't my
relationship i was like the guest star
in this other couple right and uh
and they were friends of mine so i'm
friends with both of them but closer to
the girl and basically the girl is like
hey we always wanted to have a threesome
and you know he's super into you so we
did it
and then wouldn't you know afterwards
the guy starts hitting me up on the side
all the time and telling me like how he
just wants to hook up with me by himself
and stuff and then i didn't know what to
do because i'm like do i tell my
girlfriend because we're friends but i
don't want to ruin their relationship
because they have a good thing going at
least i thought so i kind of learned a
lesson which is to never ever have a
threesome with your friends like never
all that time with the guy with the
hotel and they came out here he left her
oh i told you about that yeah i didn't
do it i didn't do it then because uh i
they came out here and they got a hotel
room near the long beach lap factory
like hoping i would do it but i said i
couldn't do it like a order and pizza
like it had to be organic like we get
drinks and if it happens it happens but
then the next time i was in vegas we
ended up doing it it was so fun it was
so you did it again
oh no i told you about it oh i told you
about it in phoenix but i didn't tell
you i'm here you didn't go one time so
you did only once uh oh wait well yeah
yeah you got two nights but in one trip
right
so twice so you got together two nights
in the same trailer it was so fun and
then
you want to leave her for that [ __ ]
little dirty bat down there that's
basically well that's what happened but
yeah yeah and she was calling you crying
you shouldn't have sucked this dick that
good it has to stop talking about you
the [ __ ] you think happens i don't know
but i mean why would you this chick is
hot as [ __ ] she's cool she's funny why
would you leave a girl that has all
these things and is letting you have
threesomes
and i even said to this dude i go just
so you know i go she's way cooler than
me because if you were with me you
wouldn't be [ __ ] other girls
like that wouldn't be happening oh no
you'd be gone in a month and a half
because you'd [ __ ] with jen or one of
your girlfriends these people are
savages
see they're savages probably and i grew
up with savages man
i think about this girl i grew up with
that played the field and until this day
i always think about it and how
we were tight we haven't spoken in 30
years because
her world changed completely but i
remember talking to her when she was 23
and 24. i remember having the werewolf
she really thought she had the world by
the balls
like you know maybe she did
no she didn't
she would date the dude that was married
and their relationship was well he was
going to leave her for her and
she was in love guy the guy had money
and he would pick her up he'd take it
for two day cruises and atlantic city
and
they got bro i tell you what i grew up
with the guy he was dynamite he was
dynamite i loved him but every time i
hung out with him there was always an
adventure he'd knock somebody out or
he'd do 90 and a 20
and get three tickets and
well you know what they used to
disappear they used to get that was the
beginning of blow
and they would get big bags and
disappear for four days and the mother
would be calling and his father would be
looking for him
and i left by that time i left i hadn't
seen her since 85
but in 87 him and her
did an all-nighter they were driving
home
drunk driving they crashed into an old
oh [ __ ] and killed the couple oh no they
let her go and he had to do the time but
guess what she pregnant
so they moved her down to florida
and nobody's ever seen anybody again no
way
nobody was allowed to see anybody again
that was boring
that's scary man
why you don't participate i still
remember she was a knockout she knew
what she was doing and what she was
doing was she was also [ __ ] two best
friends yup see she's karma and the good
looking off you dude and the other
[ __ ] always comes listen man always you
do something you open yourself
for that person to do it to you and then
you're involved in a relationship where
you get busted you apologize you promise
you never do it but in the meantime
right where were you that night why
didn't you come home oh i was mad at you
so i [ __ ] cynthia cynthia the girl you
you know and all i said now you got one
up on him he got one up on you so now
who's gonna [ __ ] who first yeah so now
you start sneaking around and he starts
sneaking around and you know what also
it's exhausting it's exhausting living a
lie is so
i can't stand lying like i would rather
i just said this so many times like
there was a guy that i was into right
and uh i told he was a friend of a comic
we know i was like hey hook me up with
your boy and he gave him my number we
start texting and we're supposed to hang
out a couple times and he kept blowing
me off so finally i go what's your deal
you got a girlfriend why do you keep
canceling guys don't cancel when they
have plans with a chick and he was like
i'll be really honest
i don't want to date you i don't want to
date anyone i'm focused on my career i
just i'm looking for girls that are hot
that are cool that just want to hook up
no guy was ever that blunt to me before
ever you know usually guys lie to you
and tell you whatever you want to hear
to [ __ ] you when he said that it was the
first time in my life i sat back and
went huh
all right so i can like use this super
hot guy for sex i mean maybe we'll have
good sex maybe not so i said to him
let's have one drink see if we have
chemistry if we do you can come home
with me if we don't call it a day and
then after that we don't have to date we
can just see what this is i swear to god
joey is the most amazing booty call we i
had him as a booty call for like
three or four months i still will hit
him up every once in a while to this day
if i'm not hooking up with anybody just
and it's amazing because he was honest
like he was just honest up front when
people are honest you can get so much
further
if you're lied to me and stuff i'd
probably be sitting here like thinking
he's one of those [ __ ] douchebag guys
honesty get you laid that's moral of the
story
honesty has gotten and i didn't know
about honesty in a relationship
i thought you gotta act like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and try to be cool
and i had a friend that was really good
looking
he was very a mama's boy he was very
polite but when he got a couple drinks
in him he would get down to basics for a
woman
and it was
beautiful like he'd be a super honest
you mean
a little too honest oh is he mean in
1982-81 i saw him work wonders with
women oh and he got away with it because
he was super good looking
but it was the way his delivery yeah
it's not the looks because there's lots
of hot guys that are not you would drink
talk to you for a little
while he's been very [ __ ] in a stupid
stinky that's what we used to call him
stinky he's my brother we don't talk we
haven't talked
in 20 years he would
ash with this side of the way like
what's the story am i next with you
like he was saying that's so ballsy it
kind of works i had a guy say to me one
time like it was the third night we hung
out we hadn't had sex and we were with a
bunch of friends and he paid for
everyone and he wasn't a rich guy but he
paid for like everybody's tab which is a
turn on as a girl when you pull that
card the girl goes oh [ __ ] this guy
doesn't mind spending money on me he's
cool to my friends like it's like panty
dropper right so then he's walking me
back to my car and i really couldn't
[ __ ] him that night because i had a
super early morning and i i had to work
and i couldn't take him home with me but
i said to him i go i can't believe you
paid for all my friends you didn't have
to do that
and uh and he goes it's all gonna be
worth it when i get that [ __ ] and i
will
and i was like
you should come home with me and then i
took him home
just because he said that like i was
fully not planning to i was like i gotta
get sleep i gotta be responsible and
then he said that and then i took him
home
it's confidence at least you're on it no
no it's i totally all the time go up to
him look him in the eye and hit him
right between the eyes even hit him a
little bit harder
so they freeze in their [ __ ] panties
but don't be a [ __ ] boy that's my whole
thing
don't lie to like my things just don't
lie to women because there are enough
girls out there now like like me i'm a
little damaged i kind of do want a
relationship but i think on the inside i
really don't so i date a little damage
i'm a little damaged yeah but i think on
the inside i want a good guy i want a
relationship but i'm scared so i date
guys that i know won't commit or that'll
hurt me just because i'm afraid of
something real so like i have a best
friend who we'd probably have great sex
and i think he's hot and we're best
friends but i won't date him because i'm
scared it might be like a real thing and
that freaks me out so i keep dating [ __ ]
boys but here's the thing i'm just
saying
look for a girl like me that's messed up
that doesn't need you to commit don't
look for a girl there's a lot of girls
that want a guy they like want a
relationship but every guy wants a girl
to commit
no they don't know another oh maybe just
not me
yeah unless they're [ __ ] crazy
every guy would you know always look at
you and go okay
this might be the one she's hot she's
this but guys always dismiss you
over one thing maybe it's something that
reminds me of that mother
one thing like jerry it's like the jerry
seinfeld thing like there's just one
little one thing if you tell the guy the
truth like let me tell you what happened
in college
i had this threesome with this big black
guy and this guy named abdullah he ain't
calling you back you know what i'm
saying like if he's someone up like if
he's late i think i've given away
if lee's from boston and you told lee
that in college and lee was thinking
about marrying you he would go home
short-circuited right there this is why
i'm going to be single forever because
guys no because guys meet me and then
they find out what i do and then the
first thing they do is hop on the
internet and google and then up pops the
church of what's happening now me
talking about
eating guys buttholes and getting peed
on in the shower
they know all that stuff no they don't
pee on your face it's just your taste no
ew i would not let a guy pee on my face
like chest down perfect yeah it wasn't
it was only one time though like i
wouldn't make it a habit because if it's
it was like splashing on my neck
what were you thinking well this is
going on like honestly i was thinking
this has to be rock bottom
like it can't get worse you know but it
did get worse that was actually the i
was actually
that was the first guy dated after my
ex-husband the first relationship pee on
you guy
lee how are you feeling over that way
i'm okay i'm wondering how long it
lasted after the p did it go the
relationship yeah a while like six more
months once you pee on somebody there
for sure that's like an engagement
that's something
let me tell you something
i only met one chick that liked pee on
that it was crazy
it's true i liked it yes you liked it oh
why i never really asked i was [ __ ] up
on drugs
what is it about urine that turns you
off she used to
want to have sex with you and then wait
around
for you to pee that first load
of pee she said that
it turned around wait around wait that
was disgusting
it was in boulder colorado it was
disgusting she was disgusting did you
pee on her at the end oh yeah ten
minutes later in the shower
no i just drag her into the shower and
just pee on her chest in her face and
her mouth no i think women are probably
a little bit more forward did she ask
you to do this like the first date
or like the second day of the first it
was a creepy relationship
it was a creepy [ __ ] because i don't
know what kind of women lee is
him first date we used to buy coke at
the same place
you and her yeah like
i thought you meant me and you no this
girl used to go over there and used to
buy coke and boulder
this started in nineteen
maybe
86
he was like always my last hookup
like because he lived on on the other
side of the boulder where i ran
so i knew her from them and i bumped
into her bars is that how you met her
did you pass her buying drugs no i i'd
pass her in this house
i had a really nice house got it she was
a nurse
she had like a a cute boyfriend at the
time but when i'd see her she'd stop and
talk to me
and i don't she told me just tell the
boyfriend you know me from
pearls or something and we talked and
the boyfriend came home and he shake my
hand this went on for a few years
i got married i still saw her every two
months well guess what
mean the boyfriend broke up
right so
she was really cute
she was a nurse but she always had the
nurse outfit on but she covered those
titties
and she used to run like 18 miles a day
her ass was wow and i'm looking at her
she's a dirty white chick just how i
like him
she was a granola chick like her armpits
probably stunk and [ __ ]
so
it's hot i used to walk in front of my
condos and bowl and i used to drive out
of there
and i'd see her walking
and after about a few months one day i
pulled up like what are you doing i
forgot what the [ __ ] her name was she's
like great to see you oh i go down to
the hospital i go across the street to
take the bus i know [ __ ] we start
talking
she goes i live up there in those
apartments
right across the street 3f whatever the
[ __ ] it was
so she just lived over there i'm married
i got a kid i ain't bothering nobody in
those days i was in and out of the
halfway house i never even thought of it
like that one day my wife leaves
and i'm in that apartment by myself and
one night you know me i get a little
package
and i [ __ ] do a few lines and i'm
like who the [ __ ] can i call for a piece
of ass wow and i go oh my god the girl
across the street
and i went across the street
i went up to her door i [ __ ] couldn't
do it
i went over she had like a sliding glass
yeah and she was just sitting on the
couch
with his street clothes
watching tv by herself i couldn't do it
really i couldn't do it it took me like
two weeks i tried to get a number
from the drug dealer he wouldn't go for
it
he wouldn't [ __ ] oh i thought you
meant you couldn't do it because like
you felt bad to do it you mean you
actually i couldn't just knock on her
[ __ ] door i was raised you got to
call a [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying really
yeah at that time it was 1991 i was we
were just separated oh you're separated
we were separated oh my god i was a
little heartbroken but still i wanted a
piece of ass and you wouldn't just knock
on her door and ask no wow and then to
me that's really more personal than a
phone call and then i got hammered and i
stayed by my balcony and i saw her get
out of her door and she had like a dog
and she went to walk them and i ran
downstairs and i may believe like i was
going to the liquor store and she's like
joy what are you doing like i'm going to
liquidate so am i we walked over to the
liquor store
and we both got like booze and she goes
what are you gonna do i'm gonna go home
come over to my place gotcha
it was over because she was like a drunk
that would give it up
the drunks
i mean you know what's funny is like
back then
neighbors would knock on your door
sometimes for things but imagine now if
someone showed up like if someone just
showed up at my apartment and knocked on
my door like a guy that i knew was
interested in me but didn't live in my
building or something i would freak the
[ __ ] out yeah that happened to me did i
tell you that no it's sure it happens to
you
that that's not normal i don't think
that happened
it's not supposed to happen but people
don't know the [ __ ] rules sometimes
yeah i had a guy show up this was
actually super creepy i had a wrap party
for my playboy channel show a guy showed
up there and he was like hey kate i live
in your building and i was like oh
that's weird i've never seen you before
he's like yeah i happen to be at the
pool and i saw the party i thought i'd
stop by it was at like the w hotel pool
so i was like oh nice to meet you you
know um say hi in the building sometime
then the next couple days i kept running
into him in my building like in a
laundry room in the garage and i was
like oh hey man it's so weird i never
saw you and now all of a sudden i'm
seeing him all the time and then the
next night i get knocked on my door it's
three o'clock in the morning it's this
guy and he's like hey i just need to
talk to you and he looks strung out
right and i didn't open the door i was
like hey man i'm in bed you should take
off and he was like i gotta talk to you
it's really important and i was like
listen i'm gonna call the cops if you
don't leave like you're freaking me out
so he leaves
i never see him again
it turns out he doesn't live in my
building he was just like some creeper
how scary is that
dog i don't suggest nobody to open up a
[ __ ] door
unless i got your number and i'll call
you
like a gentleman and go okay not gonna
come over here yeah
i got an itch
in my heart
[Laughter]
an itch in my heart and then i would be
like hang on while i puke once
you know what i'm saying like it's just
i can't imagine people coming over yeah
so i didn't
but that night with the dog i went up
there and i talked to her
i think we made out and she was like
okay you can knock whatever you want
damn because i told this i came up the
one night but i was kind of embarrassed
and i went up there one night and looked
in the curtain there she was like in
lingerie like half drunk she had been
waiting for me like since eight it's
like 12 o'clock at night
and i knocked in the door and i remember
going in there and we swapped spit and
we went at it for a little while
and after the whole thing is where she
goes wait wait
did you come on my stomach oh my
goodness because
when you pee i want you to pee on me and
i'm like what
[ __ ] up
when you pee i'm like what would you
like me to do she was in the shower
hurry up
did she want it on her face everywhere
and then she would shower right i wish
you could we could call her i wish she
still had her number i want to know why
i don't want him to have my number if
somebody lets you pee on them i want
those people forward i let my boyfriend
be on me yeah but if you still talk to
him you're [ __ ] moved the lord you
know you said something to me on this
podcast i took with me to my soul you
said if you let a guy [ __ ] you in the
butt he'll never take you to dinner
again
and i let a guy do that only one and i
told you about it on you yeah he never
took me to dinner again and then we
ended up not and then it ended never
once a guy [ __ ] him he asks
yeah yeah so don't let guys do it ever
basically no no i didn't say that let
them invest a little bit let them give
you love
let them buy maybe like an anniversary
prize some guys that's all listen
1979 the year my mother died all i
wanted to be was a purple belt
you know what i'm saying that's all
right
point of this story is some guys just
want to [ __ ] in the ass and too
that's the point of that story i like
that you somehow managed to loop in the
year your mom died with getting all i
wanted was a purple belt
do you ever cry at jiu jitsu
today i almost cried oh really no not
cry like that like crying no i cried at
yoga today
because you got emotions that are deep
into your soul
and when you start stretching instead of
blood flowing yeah you know all this
[ __ ] that comes out of you it's like
quitting coke and growing and sweating
it was embarrassing as [ __ ] and that
happens i started thinking about maybe
there's a better workout where i won't
cry
sometimes doing certain things
brings a certain emotion on you i don't
know how to describe it like yeah i know
that's last night my wife was watching
something
it was the tribute to the bee gees
oh
all right she was just scrolling she was
waiting for
the walking dead whatever the [ __ ] she
was she watches on sunday nights
to make my point she was watching this
thing with the bee gees and [ __ ]
and i'm hearing that staying alive music
and all that from that album when i sit
down
and i'm watching this and travolta goes
up there with his [ __ ] plastic
surgery and [ __ ]
and he goes you know what
you know like this uh
and i'm looking at him like ready to
laugh at him and i'm about to put the
music down like
these people trying to say and i was
like wait a second they're honoring the
bee gees yeah and number two this guy
travolta was as creepy as [ __ ]
said something that he he said somebody
this isn't your generation i still
remember
getting five of my
boys chipping in and getting a nickel
bag getting a bottle of blackberry
brandy and maybe six wine coolers
drinking this smoking this and going to
see saturday night fever in the movie
theater and i gotta tell you something
quickly
i'm sitting there with my wife and all
of a sudden just sitting there
tears
started to flow out of my eyes my nose i
couldn't breathe
because my nose got congested because
that music all of a sudden had struck a
chord it's music i saw myself
in the seventh grade walking up the hill
to catch the bus
i saw myself walking out of there
dancing
like we would dance after like with john
travolta my brother knew john travolta
he he loads trucks over it yeah
everybody always knows somebody in
jersey he was just it took me back there
and i got emotional it was i i didn't
know i didn't even stretch
i just said
it was the music today too though
something something it's the music yeah
this music came on it's just like it's
so easy man like certain songs they do
they take you right back it reminded me
you know what it was it was some song
that took me back to being a kid and my
mom the year my parents got divorced my
mom taking me to a dance class
and then this is so dumb but my mom used
to take us to dance class she was single
and then like one day a week we would go
to pizza hut and we would get to put
money in the jukebox and that was like
the highlight of my week every week and
so my mom took me there
and we would put money in the jukebox
and play this song because this whitney
houston song and then it came on today
and i started crying because i started
thinking about my brother and sister and
being little my parents divorced and
like it's crazy i still can cry over my
parents divorce
i still think it's my fault
in my thirties
you don't be [ __ ] amazing
if that happened if you walked into a
pizza hut
and you smell that pizza
every time i smell pizza i just start
crying how your memory works
that probably wouldn't sure i get soft
at different times and i go jesus
why'd that happen like i'll think of a
scent like the other day we were talking
about
statewide heaven
with rogue and all these people and i
was telling them why
i thought that would happen they
couldn't overturn it and say that they
could have robbed you know why
you know what was the main like
i said the other day it was an anthem
for so many people but most importantly
do you know how many people i know
personally that died
and that album was put in that casket no
way
played at their funeral wow oh my god if
you died after that song came out and
you were like young
that's the song that came out at your
funeral like that was how that's how
cheesy it got it became the number one
requested song at funerals no in the
[ __ ] world like that was great
most requested song or something for 10
or 15 years
something just unbelievable how many
people
requested that song on radio stations
that's why they could never overturn
that
how many people buried the loved one
with zeppelin iv in the [ __ ] castle
pretty amazing are you kidding me i
guarantee for like i said for a fact i
know two people
i'm going to get buried with your comedy
album in my life no don't do this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you said you trained this weekend the
bong got you with the one two right and
then the [ __ ] transmission fluid
with the two stars which is the three
stars how do you feel wait two how many
what's in the transmission 200
hundred two eight two two that's four
and how many stars three three that's a
thousand you can do that you sleep
that's true but you see from switching
it up
how the tolerance changes it's a
different thc
the other one this one's made with
transmission fluid
the other one's made with hash see
because if not he wouldn't get high he's
higher than [ __ ] i can tell i thought he
was 100
you know how he is he's not the [ __ ]
what did i do what is this i want some
you take whatever you want well i just
met in life like i got to buy this this
was great what this little bomb it woke
me up like it's just a mule of death oh
this is the weed of death this is called
the weed of death oh yeah you said it's
blue cookies blue cookies it's a
sativa whatever the [ __ ] thing i gotta
get into weed i really do you know i
think it would help my anxiety i think
it would be good for i have a lot of
issues i get i get
two in my head i overwhelm your mind
runs away with you which is going to be
bad and good be good
but it's funny because my wife came in
excited today
and she's like listen there's some lady
who had a baby
and then uh
she had menopause
depression and this and that so they
gave her
zoloft and this that this and that and
all of a sudden
she started smoking weed now she writes
a blog the
yeah party mommy or something like that
party mommy something she's from studio
city or something she goes you gotta
read her stuff she
so i'm gonna check it out my wife has
the name at the house i kind of want to
go and like have i've heard that you can
go and they'll like tell them what's
wrong with you and they'll
tell you what kind of weed to buy
for your issue explain something
you don't have to do that i can really
see what we're kind of
you need this in the morning
as soon as you wake up yeah after you
drink your coffee you drink coffee yeah
a little cup of coffee you get balanced
out
you wash yourself you wash your hair you
get all dialed up
then you do two one little bun
just one
just one out the window
exhale
all the bad energy that you were
thinking about in the shower
whoever you hate that day whatever you
don't want to see no hate take them out
of your life with that exhale
and the first 30 minutes 40 minutes of
your day will be the most creative
time you'll ever have in your life
you'll love it so much that you'll make
time for that creative domain i believe
it as in you have a call at nine you'll
cancel your spot the night before
because you got up at five
because you fell in love with a part of
the day that you didn't
know existed and guess what there's only
one person who lives there you
oh my god it's the spookiest [ __ ]
thing
listen when you wake up at 4 30 but you
set the timer for your coffee for 4 15
and you get up you get up at 4 15.
when i for me to when i first started
this process
which is writing a blog no matter what
on monday morning yeah
on myspace
when this started i i knew i was dead
i knew i had to do something so worst
case scenario i know plenty of comedy
writers that i just got awful yeah i
knew i could write so on mondays i
started writing a blog
and i would force myself
on mondays i would write it but i would
start preparing it the day afterwards
and a notebook oh wow all week so how i
did it was i'd get up at 4 30
and drink a little bit of coffee
i'd smoke a bong hit i'd make notes and
then i'd walk across the street
at 5 00 a.m
and walk into the ymca
with my mind on fire
okay
this is the [ __ ] and then would you work
out i don't drop this on would you work
out listen to them yeah
oh oh [ __ ] where's the lighter
i'm not ahead i'm so into this at five
in the morning
when your mind is on a sativa
maybe two or three buckets too many of
you were supposed to do yeah
and that sativa actually makes you
at 400 pounds
get up put flip-flops on
put a bathing suit on put a hooded
sweatshirt on with a t-shirt
and i would go across the street
i would [ __ ] hang up my jacket
i would have a towel
and the first thing i would do is i
would go in the steam room
and throw some eucalyptus in that
[ __ ] and they'd say don't put
the hose on the thermometer listen to me
i would bury the hose under the cold
water i would make that room and go down
to 3 000 [ __ ] degrees you could cook
a turkey in there and i'd put the
eucalyptus in there and it would open me
the [ __ ] up all that phlegm and all that
[ __ ] in my look yeah you have in your
lungs you just start spitting it out by
the chunks and it would pull
the top core of your skin out all those
little minerals that when you go to
in-n-out burger and yeah when you eat
somebody's household you have sodium in
that [ __ ] or something
you get and then i would jump listen to
what i would do i would take that same
hose
put it all over me and go into the sauna
and i would go back and forth with that
sativa mind on fire just trying to
remember the jokes and the thoughts and
then after that for about 20 minutes i'd
run out into the pool the heated pool
and i'd do laps for like 40 minutes i'd
come in i'd do a steam another song i'd
wash my [ __ ] and i'd walk back my wife
wouldn't get up to eight those days so i
get back around six i gave me two hours
yeah by myself after exercise to write
that's a young girl you can pull this
off i'm an old man i can't get up heart
attacks happen between six and four
where i am
did you take naps
sometimes but you could get up at four
and go to your spot at night and stay up
and show yourself i would take a nap
you're right i would take a nap
i'd be so tired to go home
yeah but i would do that five days a
week
just to prepare myself to write to get
my i read one of those books
by like spielberg or somebody and they
said to give yourself a window and i go
what a better window to force myself to
do two things i hate to do
exercise and write you know honestly
working out
makes me so creative i always write the
most jokes right after my work or during
like if i go for a hike i hike alone a
lot like i like to write on my hikes
while i'm hiking i just
you see [ __ ] that inspires you yeah i
really do really a weird world when you
have to like for years i went on the
road and didn't do anything healthy
now i go on the road and i'm healthier
on the road than when i am at home
because there's no raisins with covered
with yogurt in my [ __ ] closet
you know now i got pretzels at the
[ __ ] house covered with yoga i told
my wife stop buying those [ __ ] things
i come in here midnight i'm [ __ ]
starving it sounds it sounds weird but
like i read an article a few years ago
uh with uh interview with kevin hart and
he was talking about how
fitness is so important for stand-up
unbelievable yeah
and he was like i train for it like as
if i was an athlete because
yeah because your mind's got to be sharp
and for your mind to be sharp your
body's got to be sharp and i mean it's
not about like how you look but just
like being physically healthy is so huge
you know for years i just stand up and i
was a mess and part of my mess was
that i wasn't working out i was telling
my wife today that
my wife and i were talking about a shirt
we found
before we left before we got married
we lived on schroeder street this is a
charade of schrader
and there was a closet we had with old
t-shirts and one night she goes what are
we going to do with these clothes
and this was back in my [ __ ]
cigarette cocaine
reefer whatever you had i did
and she pulled out lee come out of your
coma she pulled out this white shirt
like a white t-shirt long sleeve you
should have seen what the armpits look
like oh god
they work they look like coffee filters
i don't know what i was sweating through
my body but you know why because i
wasn't sweating
when you don't sweat and you release
that [ __ ] it builds up i didn't know
listen guys did i know this at [ __ ]
30 no
but i know now i'm addicted to sweat i
am too instead of cocaine i transferred
that like now when i go on the road
when i get my
whatever sheet when they send me the
sheet the night before
first thing i do first thing i [ __ ]
do
is i look at the hotel
and i look to see what type of weights
they have
i can't swim anymore but now these
hotels have great gyms how come you
can't swim because the the [ __ ] the
water in my ear i got to go back to the
doctor wednesday at 3. because i love
swimming i love it too especially those
hotels especially friday it's empty you
swim friday and then saturday you lift
weights and do the elliptical yeah and
you put together a great little [ __ ]
workout you know when i go away now
that's the first thing i plan is that
because i know by three o'clock
i'll i'll get up i'll take a nap i watch
gang land i'll eat breakfast i'll do
radio but at three o'clock you get a
certain edge and it's the weirdest it's
nothing you almost can't wake up right
yeah until you do it your brain is like
crowded you get your [ __ ] ipod you go
down to the gym you stretch
you do the bicycle for 10 15 minutes you
do push-ups sit-ups and then i would
just lift weights i'd do a cycle and
then [ __ ] do the elliptical for 40.
and i would walk out of there
shaking but i already knew what i was
going to eat
i already knew that when i got upstairs
i already had a protein shake in my room
from cvs plus
i was going to call the front bar and
tell them to throw a salmon steak for me
blue cheese dressing i go in the shower
i wash my [ __ ] so i don't have to waste
time at the front bar i go downstairs my
salmon's ready
i go up no no no i still got an out of
right now
so while i'm digesting in the room
smoking the vapor pen
eating nicotine gum like a [ __ ]
getting ready for the 7 45 pickup you
understand me yes you're digesting
you're thinking you're resting you're
living like [ __ ] theodore you know
what i'm saying it's the best it really
is i can't and also my day is planned
for the ultimate on the road
your your days are always playing always
people come to me on the road they want
to do this they want to do that listen
you're in no danger doing nothing right
i'm going to give you the window i got
two three hours to do press
after that's it i don't give a [ __ ] of
people coming out you know also though
like and clearly i'm no kind of
psychologist or anything like that but i
get really super [ __ ] depressed and
for a while i thought like maybe i
should get on something for depression
and for me when i work out no it's
insane i go outside that's why i hike
because the sun a little bit vitamin d
is listen
i tell lee all the time people got
tested here in california did a survey
and everybody was low on vitamin d which
is crazy because we have so much
sunlight everything go outside five ten
minutes i go on these days i get up
going oh my god i can't wait to go to
jiu jitsu and i go outside and i go
you don't wanna be able to put my boxing
gloves on
i'm gonna hit the bag behind the house
oh this is so funny some rope
i'm gonna do some kettlebells i'll do
some [ __ ] bat things that they taught
you tactical fitness
i'll do the i'll do a push-up shut-ups
i'll do hip escapes on the grass that's
why
if you look at my legs i've got
scratches and [ __ ]
it's totally i basically do it to get
the sweat to make the sun
suntan you with your own personal sweat
it gives you a different type of color
i don't know about that i'm telling you
you think you get a different shade of
tan you go outside at 11 30 and you
do a body weight exercise with a
dumbbell okay for 40 minutes and let
your body really get drenched i want to
come over and hit the bag i would do
that smell the first layer of sweat that
comes out of your body and the thickness
of it it's a little on the thicker side
but just very i mean you really can't
prove it but you can because after that
you feel the next stuff that's coming
out
when you feel that and you instead of
drying off in between swings
or curls or whatever the [ __ ] you doing
just let it go you sit down in the sun
and you let that sun bake that
a day or two later look at your face
you're gonna go wow what did i do oh
it's the water treatment no
it's the way that the sweat because it
was natural it wasn't like you can't put
suntan father under here and [ __ ]
[ __ ] natural sweat the way it absorbs
the sun is the best feeling in the world
you better tan it's a better thing it is
the best feeling i tell you people
no not about gorgeous the skin color
yeah they live off their sweat i can't
go outside on the sun
you're a [ __ ] sack of [ __ ] you can do
whatever you want you're jewish you got
the world by the balls and jewish they
got arab people they got mountain they
got desert jews they got black jews did
he tell you i hit him up to go hiking i
i invited him to come hiking with me i'm
gonna make you go out and he was like
what did you write me back you said just
so you know
i do want to get in shape but i hate
working out and i hate walking
oh yeah he hates walking and i was like
well there's not really that's not
really any a way for you to get in shape
if you can't walk we're gonna have a
problem
i saw a thing on instagram they're still
doing the shaker things and i think it's
for like jiu-jitsu people but i was
hoping it was real what shaker is that
shake weights no like the when they put
the band around you and you stand on
like a machine that shakes you up and
down oh yeah yeah but you still have to
stand for that i could stand for that
how long does it take you stand on it
and it vibrates and but like you're
supposed to do other exercises with that
you don't just stand on a vibrating
machine i don't think they've been a
vibrating machine you stand and they put
a belt around you there's a thing at the
gym that uses 1950s it vibrates and it's
supposed to make you like engage all
your muscles to balance so you
tone up and burn extra calories just
standing on it i forget what it's called
it's something plate or something
i don't know
okay oh that edible got to me
oh [ __ ]
i feel great
i have my first ever sativa i do a lot
of firsts on here i wonder what else i
could do for the first time on here wait
for the show's
over hey yeah tarzan 500 milligrams and
i feel good
when did you do 500 times
what do you think you're dealing with i
don't remember hearing how much
proud of you
how did it feel about doing it from 40
days i feel high not not like the
world's going to end
that's good that's always a good feeling
sure don't think the world is ending
listen man there was a couple of nights
i had scares in the seat i'm not gonna
lie to nobody two thousand in this
listen sometimes you get [ __ ] up at
the house you forget they're in your
system
last time i was here i was freaking the
[ __ ] out were you what did you eat last
time mushrooms but i never did them well
here's what happened i brought nothing i
brought tequila
no last time and then i did an edible
sure it says free hug
free hugs and then then drink tequila we
got a half a cosby pill what do you want
to do no i don't i don't know but last
time i did weed i did edible a death
star thing and tequila and my shirt
no this is good i like this stuff all
right that's yours
that's your own personal fatigue we've
got a pipe for you but i'm saying last
time i was here
every time i would start a sentence by
the time it was so weird by the time i
get to the end of the sentence i
wouldn't remember the beginning so i
kept feeling like maybe i was
starting stories and ending different
story i was so [ __ ] up so [ __ ] that
was the only time ever and i went home
that night alone
and i swear to god i got on my phone i
started like texting every guy i've
slept with ever like come over i'm on
mushrooms and no one would come over i
just wanted to i heard sex on mushrooms
is amazing so i wouldn't try it
did you try it
what sex on mushrooms
i had a heart ah
those drugs uh never really
for me they didn't work to have sex i
didn't do mushrooms trying to move to
colorado
and two or three times i did mushroom
i didn't really want to be with anybody
because i had diarrhea and some people
the chemical imbalance immediately gives
you the squirts oh wow i don't want to
have rotten ass when you're trying to
[ __ ] suck and ew eat mushroom ass you
know what i'm saying it's bad yeah it
sounds pretty awesome mushroom mask yeah
it smells like [ __ ] in the room
so no okay hey when that happens yeah
that was a coke i've never had that i
was a coke pill
booze
sex type of [ __ ] talk for a
little while
talk some [ __ ] you know i'm saying what
are you doing
yeah your parents do okay really
no [ __ ] okay let me ask you something
you gotta take the shirt off and just
sit right looking good yeah and after a
couple more lines you take the shirt off
the pants come on and you just [ __ ]
around for a little while you dance we
plunge you dance
picturing naked like standing there just
like swinging your dick around no i'm a
professional
i'll let you dance for a little while
with the heels on yeah
the girl dances for you yeah i just sit
there i don't do that
a guy would run away screaming no i'm
very close
i'm central but when i try to dance in
heels i follow you you don't have to
dance take your heels off then hey you
don't have to dance
do you know that that i had a fan hit up
some there's some website where you can
order private videos of like people that
you're really into and this guy hit them
up was like i want a private video of
kate just doing something sexy i know
she isn't too nudity whatever so i don't
do nudity so they called me and were
like what are you down to do this guy
didn't pay a lot of money and i was like
well my friend is a stripper why doesn't
she give me a lesson in lap dancing so
she can teach me how to give a lap dance
when i tell you it was the most [ __ ]
awful terrible lap dance
i couldn't even walk from the i couldn't
walk from the wall to the chair without
stumbling like i'm saying you with an
elegant dress oh with some slits on the
side no panties on
no top on just
the smell of seduction
with heels on sun tan legs
ac dc uh
ac dc
night prowler see
a lot of women want to shake their tits
and they want to shake their ass and
show you their [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you can't dance to this song
this song is the toughest dance a woman
can dance but
she really doesn't have to dance
it's all in her hips
and how she attacks you with this
[ __ ] jam i want to hear it we're
going to listen to it real fast i don't
want to
be the people this is how though you
never heard this in the strip club when
this come on all the clumsy girls leave
but the [ __ ] know how to make money
[Laughter]
i gotta freeze right there you gotta
freeze and just move your little hips
you don't take nothing off there you go
okay you just dropped one [ __ ]
right there that's easy yeah you pull
your skirt up a little bit the bush
comes out a little bit and that's what
it's just a bush through the skirt the
70s whatever you have to have a bush to
[ __ ] seduce it listen i'm starting
the
company where you could glue a bush on
like a toupee shut the [ __ ] up with
choice i patented it already no you're
not
greenstein he's a genius you're selling
toupee for the [ __ ] just in case you
want to switch governments
you could
it sticks on with it like you only have
three hours
for it to stick on let's say you bring
the guy home you go let me go check
myself out and go see what your [ __ ]
smells like it's like a weave for your
vagina no
there's little strips
like a picture of hitler
a picture of charles manson
a thing that says love and they don't
know how's it gonna stay on when you're
[ __ ] because it's dry when you come
out they'll go uh
and then we have the original bush the
og bush that sticks on with no gel
you come out and you have that on your
[ __ ] i have a question what do you
think of an extension that goes into the
butthole like like not yet no
nobody wants that that's well some
people might listen to guys like but all
hair oh you're no no not butthole had to
be wild and tropical what we want it to
be is trimmed
and like the [ __ ] has like flowers
coming out of it
like it's just very much flowers like
baby's breasts
i saw a girl who trimmed their [ __ ]
it was perfect
no i used to lick it yeah it was
tremendous it was tremendous wait a
second but here's what i'm picturing so
you get with somebody and you start
[ __ ] and whatever it is that's
holding this on is not going to hold
when you're you know well no no no it's
an illusion so then when it comes off
you come out and go baby
what do you like with a hairy monkey or
shave monkey and he'll go i like his
shade you go too bad and you pull that
skirt up and it's a [ __ ] swamp ahead
and he'll tell you well what are you
gonna do and you'll rip it off in front
of them
and throw this [ __ ] face
like a [ __ ] you're unleashing a
superhero that's a concert that's what
the wig companies call superhero
superhero yeah i think that's great
yeah you shade take care too yeah okay
you can make a lot of money with
hipsters doing like anything
i like the dick hair idea what the [ __ ]
you think you're dealing with you think
i'm paying attention here you think i'm
hanging out what about chest hair also
give let me know that [ __ ] for the man
no you don't need a chest there
i'm still developing the [ __ ] here
because i'm trying to find like dead
chinese people i'll donate their hair
because that's the only thing that works
for anal hair it's so very fine let me
give you a shout out to you real quick
how do dead people donate things
because when before they die
they say donate my [ __ ] [ __ ] you
can only have asian error
i want to give a shout out uh my sorrows
to
mr252
hbi
tozzle252
uh he's going through a thing with his
family my prayers
go to his family jordan campbell
louis jaime rodriguez cody 1980 my
tweets will
my tweets kill fascists
david sharp sonny erickson with the
[ __ ] swedes i love you
and the stand-up fan fella chris l
and my main man burger i hope your
daughter's doing better you know i love
you [ __ ] to death
so what's next for my girl so you got
the agency now yeah you told me you want
to do action movies
well they just asked me like what would
be your ultimate
like if you were going to shoot a movie
what would you want to do and i said
like an action comedy like ride along
with chicks like something where i get
to like beat people up and do stunts
[ __ ] that you know what you want you
want to pull your hair back
you want to wear that little vest tame
it down a little bit but show them the
titties make believe there's something
even bigger than what there is under
those guns
get on tnt
get on tnt and do one of those rizzoli
and i was type show
for six years nobody gets their feelings
hurt
everybody loves you it's comedy drama
but it's funny also that'd be fun that's
what you want to get involved it'll be
fun it's action you still chase drug
dealers you beat up guys you know
you know i'm i mean i have fun doing
everything that's the thing is that
people always ask like what if i want to
host if i want to act i have fun doing
all of this so like anything i get is
fun but um
what else uh i'm working on this fuckboy
patrol show so if you're dealing with a
[ __ ] boy hit me up i want to do this
we're doing this what is the definition
of a [ __ ] boy basically uncle joey knows
the terminology there's a few
definitions in the urban dictionary but
basically it's just a guy
that is only interested in [ __ ] but
he'll lie to you to [ __ ] you and he's
like he pretends to care but he's
shallow like that's every guy no it's
not listen every guy wants to [ __ ]
finger bang you i'll tell you whatever
you guys break down it's not every girl
from your dreams no and you break down
your time i want to have children with
you my father's name is edgar you know
next thing you know you're together
because you had a nervous breakdown now
we love each other it's like what we
were talking about earlier where we were
talking about how like guys that are
[ __ ] around on a bunch of girls but
none of the girls no it's just genuinely
like guys that are [ __ ] like
not real men like guys that are just
[ __ ] around being [ __ ] boys
that's it so the show is like cops meets
cheaters kind of you date a lot of [ __ ]
boys i've dated some not on purpose it's
kind of sexy for a while like it's so
funny in your mind that's the problem
you know somebody who's doing something
and you don't mind you're in the back of
your mind you're like i'm going to win
them over
you know my [ __ ] is the best my dick is
the best there's a guy hooked up with we
we kind of dated but really it was just
well this happens to me a lot where i
think i'm dating someone but we're
really just having sex so we were kind
of dating and long story short the sex
was so [ __ ] good i was so blind to
everything else we finally quit seeing
each other
and then he hit me back up not too long
ago to to hook up and i'm not dating
anyone or [ __ ] anyone so i was like
sure let's do it we get together
and we have the best sex right and then
i'm hitting him up a few days later
because i want to hook up again and he
was like i'm busy and i was like
it's been i was like it's been a week
let's just [ __ ] like [ __ ] me already
like when are you free and he wrote back
hey
just because i gave you some amazing
dick don't get an attitude with me
that's what he wrote me back and all i
thought is
that's
the the whole thing with fuckboys is
that it's just like these guys that
realize that the tables are kind of
turned out here like a great dick is
hard to find
and they know and he knows and he knows
i'm not hooking up with a lot of guys he
knows me so he knows like in this
scenario like you know guys always say
[ __ ] has the power in this scenario the
dick has the power
that's like basically a fuckboy is a guy
who realizes that the dick has the power
i really like it so he's just mad that
he's has the power
sometimes the man if a guy is really
good in bad i hate to admit it but he
does have a lot of power because that's
very hard to find like i can tell you're
good in bed just no i'm not like come on
no you don't i come in the middle always
i can tell that you threw it down
because you know you talk about choking
girls oh yeah you gotta [ __ ] you know
it wasn't my growing up doing but when i
met the stripper she used to make me
give her a beating before sex a good
beating but that's what i'm saying so
like that's what makes a guy good in bed
it's not about how fast he comes it's
about the attitude it's about that like
being a man
across the floor before i eat your [ __ ]
it's okay once if we're [ __ ] up on
drugs
if you consent to it it's okay
i remember one time she went to vegas or
something
and she came back on a monday and she
goes i didn't cheat on you
i went to vegas and hang out with my
girls at that point i didn't give a [ __ ]
i'll never forget i just pulled her by
her hair and threw into these tables
like there were these barstools i just
that's what she wanted you just made me
re-evaluate my whole
dating life because you said it's okay
once and we're [ __ ] up on drugs and
i'm like what that's what i expect in
all my relationships like i expect that
all the time when a guy doesn't [ __ ] me
like that i don't come over your house
on a wednesday and hit you with a
shot to the mouth
and tell me to suck my dick you filthy i
don't mean like show up in the middle of
the day out of the blue and do it
although if we're dating that's cool no
if it's a friday night we got a couple
of [ __ ] sleeping pills yeah well yeah
we're getting some heroin and [ __ ]
you're right we tie you up a little bit
and we [ __ ] you good you know the deal i
don't mean in the middle of the day like
you pop by for lunch and just start
slapping me dip your [ __ ] left side
who's we by the way why is there two
people no i'm just saying i'm just
saying that me and the camera or lee in
the camera the camera
yeah
you dip your nut sack in your mouth and
maybe do you ever do you ever tape your
sex capades never never disgusting not
even for yourself to watch no huh i
wouldn't have the heart to do something
like that to yourself to nobody
what myself
well i mean you could do it with your
wife no
no
do guys still jerk off to their wives
ever
i'm asking lee like he knows
i always wondered that like once you're
with a girl if you ever think about her
because when i
i always turn the conversation to sex on
this show i need to change that no no
this is who you are you like doing this
[ __ ] you love the lifestyle i only wish
that
you know you're gonna study boyfriend he
cleans up your little [ __ ] act and
check and recover joe yeah you get used
to one dick for four or five years then
you marry him i love one day pray to god
that a sex tape don't come out of you or
this guy there's no sex tape you never
know with these creepy people but
there's the porno guy must have cameras
in this house
you know what i'm saying you gotta
assume as soon as he goes and he sneezes
and that's the coach for cameras to turn
on
and there you are i love you i want this
to be a relationship no and all of a
sudden you get a hit show on abc and
also this pops up
you know as i am so be careful you know
i love you to that and that [ __ ]
does happen in this town
i don't trust nothing in this town you
have a point i don't trust the [ __ ]
thing in this town there's these things
that people do
in this town they go to these [ __ ]
massage places
if you go to these massage places they
all got [ __ ] cameras
you think you i know for in the room i
asked a friend of mine that goes to the
orphan
if there's a mirror in his room
and he goes there's a mirror in all the
rooms oh of course i don't know [ __ ]
what you say lee you know what i may be
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but maybe i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] do
you think they're recording everyone
just in case they catch somebody famous
or something
somebody famous
somebody rubs up a girl maybe the tape's
not playing maybe it's not the best
quality yeah it's not a bad idea it's
not a bad idea for a business to open a
massage parlor and put a camera in there
but the thing is it's illegal to tape
someone without their consent and when i
actually so follow what are they doing
in [ __ ] vegas
you can in vegas
but in vegas there's even some rule you
have to have one party's consent if
you're filming two or something listen
in vegas make sure just
i've told leaders a thousand times in
vegas you got to assume they're taping
you while you're in the shower
you have to assume
you have to assume then i would never
shower or the whole time you assume
these things can't no you don't yes you
do that they're taping you in the shower
you have to you have to look at every
situation anymore it's 2007. then i
could never shower i didn't say that no
but then they would have naked tape on
me i didn't say that i said always
assume
that they could be watching young las
vegas
they're not [ __ ] they don't have 18
million in the basement
and not be watching what's in that
[ __ ] building at all times
i remember getting coked up in those
rooms and thinking to myself like are
they watching me is that anytime
somebody got a knock on the door and
nobody ever did i was wrong but just in
case now with what's going on in this
country and [ __ ]
i would assume they're taping you
everywhere
i guess you i guess listen i don't see
no poles out here with cameras
so unless we planted a mouse
for the israeli army or something we
should be good but you always have to
assume in today's world it's creepy
that's somebody's lesson when you're on
the phone well who did i read bill gates
always keeps a piece of tape over his
webcam on his laptop because he thinks
people are watching always you have to
assume
that you are whacking off giggling like
an [ __ ]
and somebody in russia is throwing darts
in your head come on look at this
[ __ ] babushka yeah all right i'm
gonna think about that next time i did
live with a guy when i first moved to la
that was positive it was had cameras
everywhere
everywhere it's something that's big now
it's big it's easy to do
it's [ __ ] super so easy to hide them
it's super [ __ ] simple true you get
these guys in the douche bags they tweet
yeah what do they call that game where
you go on there and you can't bro
you know you scroll
when the [ __ ] that what's that happily
that you scroll if you want [ __ ] you go
yes
tinder
you know you meet someone else it's that
game where if you hear
one [ __ ] yeah and if you hit what
everybody somebody like meet me at the
railroads tinder is a dating app
whatever the [ __ ] it is you know what
i'm saying you trust everybody on there
[ __ ] no i would never invite someone
over do you know what i do on there did
i ever tell you what i do on tinder what
are you doing i go on tinder when i'm
bored i just do this when i'm before
surprise me
i go on tinder
and i message guys and i pretend i just
want like an easy hookup but then i act
as crazy as i can on purpose and i try
to get the guys to block me like i try
to see how much crazy guys will put up
with if they're super horny and they
want to [ __ ] and i write them all kinds
of like dumb [ __ ]
like i wrote to a guy and i was like
this is a true story i wrote to a guy
and i said that um i really wanted to
have sex i was mad at my boyfriend
because he cheated on me and i really
wanted to have sex in his car
and this guy is a cop and he wrote back
oh you know what i'm a cop and i
actually know how to break into cars
and i was like okay well he works at
high school so i want to do it during
the day
and uh i want to get in the car have sex
and then i want to take polaroids and
leave the photos in the car
and the guy was like great what high
school what time should i meet this guy
did not care he was willing to lose his
job to [ __ ] and then i was like and also
i want you to poop in the car i want you
to take a crap on the passenger seat and
leave it there for him and he was like
okay that might be a problem sometimes i
have trouble pooping in public
i was like i'll bring you diuretics i
just kept adding more and more [ __ ] onto
the equation and you just kept saying
and i have this guy's photo
off of this app off of tinder and he has
his police outfit on so i guess police
badge everything is there that's how bad
guys on tinder just wanna [ __ ]
they will say they will i literally have
told guys i'm an axe murderer i told a
guy that i needed to have sex i just got
out of prison and they're like cool what
time where do you live i told a guy that
i only [ __ ] with rattlesnakes in my bed
now where you are on tinder as soon as
you open the app these are people that
are local to you yes within how many
minutes
it you can set the mileage for whatever
you want what did you say that like 20
miles that's 25 minutes with the without
traffic right you ain't [ __ ] around
are you i don't really [ __ ] them i've
never met a guy of tinder i just do it
to [ __ ] with them for fun
one of these days when these guys are
gonna choke you today
he's gonna see your little youtube
videos you're gonna see a little [ __ ]
well now like you can see that face and
that smile now it kind of happens yeah
you gotta get it together you know what
i'm saying they're gonna [ __ ] you that
you're playing with the devil on that
side they'll come they don't [ __ ] around
though when they realize it's a joke
then i give them tickets to a show what
joke ain't no [ __ ] joke when they go
crazy you use that movie what's the
strip club of black people that came out
with ice cube and
strip club remember oh my god it came
out like a 99 the club
players club i've never seen it you've
never seen the players club i'm going to
write it down this is what i'm talking
about lisa at least i had have you
you've never seen the plan no why
wouldn't he
right he watches parks and records
so you didn't come out huh what year did
they come out 99 2000 i'm sorry i was
11. i wasn't watching the players club
it was like a chris tucker type movie
about strippers and yeah
the girl that moves in with who else
academy award what's the comedian the
black kid that did the movie with tom
cruise
in the cab driver
jamie foxx is in it
it's a good lineup jamie foxx ice cube
you gotta watch it
yeah you know i'm gonna give you a
bernie mac bernie mac was right howard
michael clark duncan wow face on love
lisa ray mccoy the player's calling the
players [ __ ] club
john amos i can't help you oh yeah
charlie murphy
got arrested
the little black dude it's [ __ ] off
the chain jack
i'm not going to end up in the players
but
i need you i need you here you're
beautiful you're my girl i love you i
need you to be healthy what's going on
with you tonight how you feeling
are you relating to the [ __ ] stars or
what
i'm feeling i'm feeling [ __ ] up but
i'm okay i'm feeling [ __ ] up but i'm
okay
that's my dog over there he's getting
ready he's coming up up to uh leveling
live when is the old man come in don't
don't
when does he come in wednesday
uh-huh beautiful
perfect we picked the old man up we got
a bag of [ __ ] stars from you're there
wednesday to sunday no i'm doing tuesday
wednesday we're going to prep the old
man and get them ready for thursday oh i
just can't throw them to the wolves on
thursday only an animal would do
something like that
and don't take them to lizard me places
take them to the cactus turn them onto
some
good tacos stop [ __ ] around with him
i don't bring my legend somebody got him
sick last time this [ __ ] you guys
i didn't get him sick i only gave him
stars of death and love that's all i
ever get
[Laughter]
that's all he's all you give out
that's what god's love he wants love and
stars of death the father he don't care
about anything else
you excited how long is he staying for
away he's leaving monday morning
you're driving for your uber
uh i'll probably have to over monday
morning why what are you doing with your
life
because i have work i do
what kind of work do you do on monday
morning
i usually put up a podcast
this one or another one a different one
oh these are
times look at you he's a man of many pun
i should have lee help me i want to do
another podcast about pooping did i tell
you about it sounds like a hit
i swear to god nicole amy schreiber guy
we want to do a podcast called the poop
cat look at lee crack the funnies and
[ __ ] i know look at that [ __ ] we're
going to do a show it's going to be
called the poop cast and it's just going
to be he has an idea of what's going to
work and what's not going to he's going
to be the first
i dare you to call me you're never going
to call back don't you think that it'd
be so funny to have a different guest
every week tell a story about pooping
their pants and that's the whole show
just 10 minutes really who's going to be
your sponsor toilet paper yeah i mean
squatty potty
no you need to have respectable people
you know what i'm saying who wouldn't
tell that story you probably have a
great [ __ ] in your pants story i'll bet
you've [ __ ] your pants at least twice
about 10 times see yeah but i don't want
to tell the stories to people you just
nobody wants to hear that [ __ ] that's
civilized it's funny no
who could sit there and talk about this
[ __ ]
that you think [ __ ] we just talked about
girls getting peed on well that's
completely different that's sexual
me taking a [ __ ] into somebody's
backyard
right where the kids swing is is not uh
that's the story i want to hear why the
[ __ ] in the shower was not not a good
thing
yeah that's not [ __ ] your pants in
the shower
why'd you [ __ ] in the shower because
it's the quickest hold it's the same
it's the same pipe no one sits in the
shower if you're lazy sometimes you just
open up your [ __ ] you do too i haven't
in a while i was [ __ ] it especially
if i'm in a hotel and they got like a
big hole but what if it's not or
sometimes i'll take the thing off
and i'll pop and let that [ __ ] go right
down that tube
i'll push it in there with my finger no
you don't yes i do oh my god is that
what you want to hear
so you hear white people stories
i was running down the street in my
sweatpants and i went to starbucks and
no you want to hear my [ __ ] i got [ __ ]
stories
putting it down your [ __ ] toilet with
your toe yeah you tell that's what i
don't know
i remember [ __ ] in the tub and pick it
up and throw it in the toilet
six feet away changing my mind all right
then what's wrong with me i'm a
professional what that does is that what
you want to [ __ ] hear yeah i mean i
guess it's kind of fun
but that was funny you start a podcast
for people who are very sincere
about their first heartbreak
if they start [ __ ] around you're
going to tell them i'm throwing you off
the show
i want people to come in
and talk about their first heartbreak
and how that heartbreak
has affected you even now today that's
interesting it really is interesting i
do last week a couple weeks ago
there was a woman on the podcast and i
talked about a story that i wanted to
apologize to a girl and i took her
virginity and then told her i couldn't
date her anymore because she told me a
story that her [ __ ] mother was dead
i left there
at that age
i didn't i never heard that
at the age of 15 nobody ever told me
that i never met nobody who didn't have
a mother yeah so you told me you didn't
have a mother the first time i didn't
want to [ __ ] you no more really i was
done i went to basketball camp i started
dating a different girl wow three months
later when i found my mother dead i
thought about that girl oh so till this
day you know what i'm saying like i have
a a really weird connection with the
girl but that's interesting
yeah it's always bothering me like
things like that thing is how do you
know your first heartbreak
like i mean because everybody knows
their first heartbreak unless they're
[ __ ] [ __ ] no but i mean like
because there were guys that i thought
broke my heart but then there's one that
like definitely well super broken here's
the thing there's times you date people
and at the time you break up you think
he broke your heart right it's maybe two
or three down the line that really break
your heart yeah from heartbreak you
learn about heartbreak but you also
learn how to get yourself out of
heartbreaking this is so those are the
fun stories you know so true like uh
texting them from 45 phone numbers
i said i'm done with all this first of
all i had gone through
29 [ __ ] pounds of coke in four months
and i had gone through 30 women
and every story i remember
uh
kate quigley is one filthier than the
other but i enjoyed craig quigley when i
was going on yeah but till today there's
times i'm sitting there going
i wonder what the [ __ ] happened to that
girl what she thinks happened today yeah
like we're both 50 we're both 21 at the
time yeah
but it was just filth
it was just plain filth like i was just
getting you know i always believed in
like let's say we swap spin i suck your
titties i fingered you
i [ __ ] you i ate your [ __ ] that was
it i came in your stomach
this was like you know this is the first
time you met this person they're in your
hotel room they're naked an hour later
you're doing blow you're fingering them
and next thing you know it gets hot and
nasty for four hours
[ __ ] that like dice says you wouldn't do
to a farm animal
and also when you pass out from the
quaaludes and you wake up next that
person you're like
that's a piece of ass but i can't have
it around
if she sucked my balls for two hours
straight i can't you know like it's one
of those disgusting things that [ __ ]
never happens to me on the road i guess
no no no no no no no no this is not on
the road oh it's not on the road this is
just when you're young this was in 1984
when i was kind of homeless and i was
just going out to bars i would show up
kind of homeless
you think you're not good in bed you're
[ __ ] homeless getting girls to
[ __ ]
how hard it is to get laid homeless
listen you go to a blog i listen it was
it wasn't hard in those days
to go to a bar i would get an eight ball
and i would save a gram for after three
a.m
and i would sell the gram to make money
for the bar and you'd walk in there at
one o'clock and you just broke up with
your boyfriend but i know you like to do
coke yeah and we start talking and also
that three like what are you gonna do i
would play innocent that's true what are
you gonna do i don't know
where do you live do you live close by
no no i was going to get a hotel room to
like why what happened to where you live
they're painting i wouldn't make up a
story they're painting so they gave me
money to get a hotel room was with a
dick nut no way when you come to my
place you know i have vodka over there
and gin oh my god you're going down you
know
it was just a night of phil very real
very
seldom that i leave those nights without
something wow like you're always left
with a [ __ ] or they fingered
themselves in front of you there was
always some really pointed disgust yeah
there was always at that time frame
there was always
one point of disgust
i went on like a four weekend tear in a
row
with four attractive women
that would never look at me in any other
situation of their life
and i made them do things
that were totally utterly [ __ ]
disgusting
to this day i say a prayer for all of
them
every day you like candles from them in
jersey yeah it was terrible
and then after i got cleaned up i met a
girl in cresco new jersey who was a
sweet flower girl
and she didn't do drugs and we would
just cook up and
drink a beer and then i started messing
no sex
no sex figuring
i didn't get laid for a long time
like eight months oh yeah we talked
about that and then i got on the plane
and that was it
i don't know how girls can just like
make out and hook up a little bit and
not have sex like once i get turned on
it's really hard for me to stay down oh
my god
i don't have much of a second third base
area i'm a first base to home run chick
dirty white chick
that was the stewardess
um people's express
and we were talking on the plane we kept
talking and i knew this chick was dirty
and i threw a bait at her i said let me
ask you something what if we went to
when we get in denver
we got a piece and she goes what are you
talking about
like oh maybe we got an eight ball and
she goes what are you talking about if i
get a name ball let's go back to the
hotel room let me eat your [ __ ]
and she looked at me and she was like
okay
and she goes meet me by luggage
and we met my luggage we walked out
there like we knew each other and we
took a cab to like a hotel there was no
cocaine she kept asking me with the
whole cocaine you never got it [ __ ] no
i didn't even drink
that's how strong my game was i didn't
even shut up i was eight months without
a piece of [ __ ] i had been striking out
three [ __ ] times on fridays and
satellites i thought i was going mental
i thought there was something wrong with
me i was lifting weights i was running
remember you saying i was in shape
i had a gold chain i had bracelets gold
chain that's what happened yeah that's
why you were getting nice i wasn't
getting dick
and all of a sudden i got this [ __ ]
stewardess
from ohio or somewhere
back in the room with a hairy [ __ ]
just giving me everything she's got i
thought i'd go home and she ripped it
off no that's what i was hoping
who the [ __ ] would have thought that
after all that time
i would meet a girl on a [ __ ] plane
and have sex
and then i got she left and i left
i took a bus to boulder
and as i'm walking the street of boulder
i met another girl
and that night we didn't have sex but
two days later
we had it's like you opened the flood
gates it's like i could i could not get
arrested for eight months
and all of a sudden i had two women i
was talking to on the phone and [ __ ]
that's kind of how it goes i think
that's how it is for me like i i really
the last like three months have not
dated or talked to anyone and then all
of a sudden there's like a bunch there's
like i could see it coming i could see
you're gonna meet a nice guy but you're
gonna be a pain in the ass
you want to [ __ ] the strip no i don't no
i don't i really don't i'm done with
that i don't i'm done with that so weird
huh i was listening to that i was
listening to rat the other day
the other day i was listening to ozzy's
boneyard with jim norton
and he was playing one of those rat
songs
but i i kept remembering how he
referenced the sex
how important it was and for a while
i always knew i was shitty of sex
so i wouldn't hit on women for that i
would always go i'm not going to hit on
them just because i don't want to go
through that [ __ ] nightmare again i
would feel uncomfortable and [ __ ]
i didn't have much to offer unless i get
really dirty with you and some women
didn't like when you got really dirty
with them it was [ __ ] crazy it was
tough to
it's not good okay quickly
it's not good i can't believe that yeah
it's crazy it's [ __ ] my i'm in my
head about it like i'm going to get
hypnotized when was that
because when my heart beats a lot what
happened when was that that you felt
that way
i think it started in 1985.
oh wow i was about 22 when i first
when that really went before that
i was having sex but kid sex yeah six
minutes seven minutes
that's kids [ __ ] it's getting eight
minutes
i was eating a little bit of [ __ ] yeah
if you sucked it you sucked it if you
didn't i was fine with it in those days
i didn't want you to go against your
basic rules oh my god i was one of those
but it's like anything else once you
come in a woman's mouth that's all you
want to do you're like i'm coming and
everybody's [ __ ] man
i don't like it yeah well guess what
papa's in town
would you even date a girl honestly like
now you're married but like i met a girl
when i was just in texas who was like
you know what i don't blow guys she said
i just don't it doesn't matter who he is
doesn't matter how much i like him i
don't do that and when they ask me i
just say i don't do that and i go who
dates you like i can't imagine any guy
being eventually gonna suck dick right
eventually yeah every man likes that
dick sucked on payday you know something
paid days every friday
they bring home the rooster
it's and you know what's sad a lot of
guys in the beginning of a relationship
will say that's fine
if i love you i love you but guess what
those guys are going to bother you when
you're going through pregnancy they're
going to ask you for a blood job and now
you got to call that bluff well you told
me you were fine with well that was
before you got knocked out
now well go help yourself with your hand
no no no no tell them from the beginning
i like my dick sucked
eight different ways the least way i
like it is with an ice cube in your
mouth
everything else i don't give a [ __ ] put
an ice cream in your mouth strike my nut
sack and put whipped cream on my dick
and take it for dessert that's the kind
of dick sucking i'm looking for a good
american and at the end i just blow a
[ __ ] hole in your throat with two or
three ounces of [ __ ] sperm juice
that'll [ __ ] your [ __ ] jugular for
three hours that's crazy you don't know
what you have in your mouth whether it's
a martini
you don't know what's in your oh my god
oh ice in your mouth
that sounds awful you never suck to
think what i said in there no oh my gosh
a little piece of ice cube oh you suck
the guy's balls no come on kate
don't tell me next time that's good
those guys over absolutely
pop that little ice cube i used to pop
the ice in your [ __ ] take it out and
pop it in my mouth
yeah i've had guys do it to me i've
never done it to a guy did you go crazy
when they took the ice cube out of your
snatch and threw it in their mouth like
a [ __ ] lozenger i like i like some
ice yeah i like all that [ __ ]
i did it to this little white christian
girl from kansas i was fingering in the
ice machine room she looks like a little
waitress and [ __ ] i just started coming
nice machine i'm all cooked up
i'm all coked up and volumed up this
poor girl was on the up and up
she had like a a bahama mama and then we
started i love this girl we saw that
swap in space like maybe our second date
she's hammered i'm hammering on the
pills and the blowing finger and it was
right next to the ice machine i pulled
away from the ice machine
i took her hand ice cubes and i stuck
him up a [ __ ] she just looked at me
like she was a christian she played the
organ at the church
i whipped that ice out and i put it in
my mouth and i made a swap spit with me
i could feel her knees shivering you
understand me
she didn't know what it hit her damn
college damn
and her dad owned the hotel so he gave
her the hotel she had any room she
wanted to there
but she had a roommate a chinese girl
a korean girl and
so i fell in love with this girl we
would go in there while she was
roommates and give me little hand jobs
and a little side blower
both she was just a college girl no
me and this girl fell in love i really
loved it
but the korean girl was banging
and i knew
that
i knew she was the devil in cardiff
in my heart i never thought about it i
could be honest with you i just got
divorced
you're such a good guy no because you
know what man
i could lie to you and tell you yeah i
looked at her a couple times and said
i'd love to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of it but
yeah at the same time i just gotten
divorced yeah i was trying to be
you know so now but hold on this story
changes
about six months later we're at a party
at a wedding
and this girl pulls me aside and says
listen
i wanted to tell you something in about
three months
i'm moving to new york i got a job
working for an ad agency
you know that's what i went to school
for i'm making a great salary they're
going to pay for apartment for the first
year
i said there's funding what do you want
to do and she goes we'll talk about it
right before i leave
and it was fine but something had
happened
the little asian girl got a job at the
dealership i worked at the toyota oh
[ __ ] so we became little friends sure
you know and i would see her whenever
she drank at lunch
she was a little crazy
she would say goofy things to me if you
show me yours i'll show you mine
are you serious and she goes no i'm just
testing you you crazy [ __ ] she
was my friend i like that
so this girl left
and i told like i'll be in new york in
about six weeks to see you i'll go out
there and do comedy that's why i was
gonna get paid this is 19
oh my god guys this is 1993. yeah i was
just getting 10 minutes if i was lucky
yeah
and i
you know staying home
so guess what else happened
this girl you guys hooked up her
boyfriend up two years
also
wanted to move to seattle
to find himself
and i'm looking at this girl she's
telling me the story of the dealership
and i'm looking at this girl
she's 24.
so
when you were 20 super hot you're ready
she's ready to go she just needed a band
leader
that's all she needed was a band leader
to get into a destination right right
and comes uncle joey lead the
and in my heart i could say it like a
man i didn't it wasn't my intention in
my heart i tried to not keep the
relationship open with this girl
but i knew this wouldn't be good
and i didn't to be honest here i didn't
think this was gonna happen she was that
high level good looking damn you thought
she was out of your league i mean
perfect titties perfect hips yeah it's
cute
witty americanized yeah born in korea
but raised here perfect tall
she liked to you climb on her face
because the warmth from the [ __ ] would
make her cut
this is tremendous when i heard this
[ __ ] she said that so listen to me so
this goes on for about a month a month
and a half me and her goombas
she's hanging out at the comedy shows
i'm giving her a ride home
one night i take her home and she goes i
really don't want to go home i'm sick of
going up there alone can i sleep over
there by you i had like a [ __ ] eight
ball with coke on me i go
come on we went back to my house i asked
the next thing though she's taking the
panties or we had to do it
and we stayed in that room for four days
she i was i had never been with an asian
woman before
she was beautiful that sakisaki juice
that came out of her monkey
had me all [ __ ] up jack
she was very sexual very beautiful
and we just pretty much had a
relationship i mean
this girl was calling me and she'd be
laying next to me
oh what are you doing no no no the chick
in new york what ah oh
would be calling me and i'd be with the
[ __ ] chick
mugging up
oh [ __ ] i forgot all about the other
girl but then the korean chick pulled a
double cross on me
she had a job and she told me she was
going to dinner with some dudes and some
girls and [ __ ]
and i had a weird [ __ ] feeling
so at night about midnight i went over
and there was one dude up there and he
was naked so i stopped talking to this
freak so you were mad that she was
hooking up with him even though you had
a girlfriend you know how he did
it's such a double standard it really
[ __ ] it really is i was 30 something
years old guys get so guys getting
territorial this was when i first got
divorced
and i had just gone into this game i
didn't know this dating game i had been
out of the game for seven [ __ ] i get
it i can relate and you know she's back
and i didn't talk to her for a while but
the person was so good sure and the
freakiness was so hot
but she was crazy she's one of those
girls that would get a period and have
to go to the hospital
why what she would start yelling and
have nervous it made her that crazy
nervous breakdown so every other one she
would have to call the hospital like the
day before and go get ready no way yeah
[ __ ] your mother's shoulder
yeah i think they can put you on
something something yeah it was crazy at
that time she didn't know wow and she
moved to korea
she moved to korea
broke my heart now i had not one of them
one was in new york and the other one
wasn't [ __ ] korea i'm in colorado
doing comedy by myself look at that poor
bastard
falling asleep yeah he's snoring over
there
like i hit you through the mic you see
that
and uh it was heartbreak like i was
heartbroken
but here's the snoozer i'm back in new
york i'm selling cars
i'm doing two spots tonight
and you know what on the weekends that
little white girl julie
is letting me come over and eat a [ __ ]
and fool around with
and we'd go to the village and get a
slice of pizza but she wanted nothing to
do with me wow she wanted an open
relationship damn but every week i would
connive her into getting a hotel let me
give you a stab and
we were doing okay she invited me over
on a wednesday
i went over there with my buddy she
brought her girlfriend they hit it off i
hit it off with her that night
everything was going great
i went back over to that friday spent
the night whenever on saturday
left sunday that was the first time i
spent two days with her oh wow i'm doing
comedy she came to my show i ate dicks
but who cared you're basically dating i
really wanted this to work with this
girl yeah do you know i leave a sunday i
give her a kiss
i was driving a limo i get in the
[ __ ] limo driving home monday i was
delivering food from 10 to 22
and then i would go home take a shower
and deliver and drive the limo wow
i go to nbc studios and i pick up the
daily shots
as i'm driving my painting goes off it's
this girl in new york
and i call her up and i know what's
going on she goes so
i just got a call from kansas
the girl
she came back and she went crazy one
night oh [ __ ] she ratted you um
the asian girl the asian girl called me
at three in the morning crying the guilt
had gotten so bad to her that she uh
she [ __ ] flipped out they put her in
oh my god holy [ __ ] this is after the
three weekends in a row of love oh my
god
this
this korean girl dropped a bomb on me
that word
that one wasn't the dud
she called the girl and came clean with
how long our affair was why would you do
that
i think she was really crazy she had to
be the guilty oh me and the girl but
here's where it gets better
that's 1993
92.
i met another girl in 95.
you hook up in michigan she comes to
boulder she wants to lick my [ __ ]
that's the one that said turn it over
i want to give you a rusty trombone it
all comes back around you [ __ ] crazy
she moves to seattle the pussy's so good
three weeks later uncle joey has to move
to seattle i've never done it before in
my life but i've never had stripper
dirty michigan [ __ ] that makes me do
dirty things and
i know she's so good you moved to
seattle i knew she had a disease like i
knew this girl had a disease oh my god
whenever i itch i think about it like i
know she gave me something you know
so i moved to seattle
we we lived
i forget by the beach i go or whatever
that is
whatever that beach is and we lived in
the u district
and one day i'm pulling in my car i'm
gonna go to the movie theater i pull him
with my car to the gas station
as i'm filling it up with gas i turn
around
and it's paul her ex-boyfriend
the korean girls the guy that left her
that moved to seattle no way here i am
oh my god and this guy was a doorman
like he was a big dude holy [ __ ] he came
up to me he had tears in his eyes and he
was like
i can't believe you did that
the guilt made her end up in a [ __ ]
mental home
she barely got out of there like a month
ago
yeah this chick was out of it i can't
believe they were still talking
her and him so were they still like
together when he was in seattle they
were still talking kind of sort of wow
they were trying to work things out you
drove her to a vent the dick was so no
you put her in the hospital thing the
the the [ __ ] guilt drove her crazy
which i understood it was a lot of guilt
they moved there together they were
fraternity sisters together oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah no no no no no i think back now but
the funny thing is that was 1993
we never talked again the longest yard
came out and there was this website that
they had put up it was owned by gabriel
and this guy in el paso latino
comedy.com
and one day the owner goes he goes you
know your message boards there i knew
nothing what a message board was look at
this poor best at least
i knew nothing what a message board was
or how to and i went to the message
board he showed me how to go back there
and there was a message from the korean
girl
and she said congratulations
i always knew she goes you were really
serious about it you knew what you
wanted to do
and she goes guess where i live she
lived in my hometown where the cubans do
it i thought you were going to say like
an insane assassin
she lived in north bergen with a cuban
dude she was very proud of me and she
had two kids
and uh it was really happy that she
forgave me
she didn't want to talk to me which is
cool as long as she forgave me yeah you
know what her and i went to see seinfeld
together
like as friends do you know what i'm
saying like we were really friendly she
didn't really have a reason to be mad at
you she you know you she knew you had
the girlfriend
it's not like
me and her taking my daughter to the zoo
my daughter falling asleep and me and
her pulling over and [ __ ] her from
behind at a phone booth in the dead of
the winter like that's how hot she was
okay with your daughter in the asleep in
the car
oh my god
this chick just took me to a new
dimension i was shocked like
just come all over myself like she'd be
in the car and i would just have come in
my jeans damn she would always want me
to rip her clothes off
we would do the first time me and her
were really tight really [ __ ] tight
man
and she was coming to my comedy shows
with my friends and she would have a few
drinks wow and like a day before that
comedy show she started talking crazy
[ __ ]
like yeah well these nights i'm gonna
sleep over and we can watch movies and
i'm like i don't know how this is gonna
work out man
this is how it started and we're like
talking and that tuesday night was steak
night at the broker in for 15 bucks yeah
plus you got a comedy ticket a baked
potato a salad and a water or something
and we were there and she had a few
drinks on
and her and i had been talking about her
sleeping over something she came up to
me at this bar
and she was walking me out to the car
i had an acura integra at the time a
brand new 93. that i could not afford
i bought it just to because i was
getting divorced and i wanted to pick up
young girls
and acura put her in the front seat
and she i never forget she had like a
business skirt on
with simple heels on and stockings she
just opened up her legs and she told me
rip my stockings on damn i ripped the
stockings off i ripped the skirt off her
blouse was beautiful and white with
those buttons
i just ripped that open i ripped her bro
playing her [ __ ] i basically left her
nude in the car so i finished doing
comedy
and then we went back to my house jesus
i finished her off and i had to give her
like my clothes to go home her brother
was staying with her
she came in with that jacket ripped to
shreds like but that's what turned her
on sure of course how would that not
turn she was amazing
like you would actually see a thing
drop out of her monkey like a little boo
and you and that would turn you on
you're like oh my god this is
this is just amazing yeah
it was crazy cake damn was i in love
no i wasn't not
look the way you asked me
it's hard not to confuse it when it's
that intense you're like you don't know
you don't know at the time your brain is
like feeling this intense feeling and
it's like it's oh
but that kind of sex is i've only had
that with two people and it was like
both those guys so hard to quit
harder than anything i've ever quit
to be honest the people i fell in love
with were the ones that weren't that
good at sex yeah that's what people say
because i always felt inferior so
i a woman that comes in on the third day
she's like hold on hold on
i want to jump off your bureau and land
on your [ __ ] first
this girl's been around the block a
little bit you know what i'm saying jump
off your beard yeah when she comes to
your house for dinner
you gotta disinfect the fork your mom
can't eat off that fork spiderman of
fuzzy yeah you never know
we all want a [ __ ] but we don't want it
i know
someone said that
and we don't want you know you suck dick
before okay one time in the eighth grade
that's it that's what we want to hear i
didn't like it i puked really all this
time now guys always understood no they
didn't you've been sucking dicks right
that's what they want to think
yeah we don't want to know nothing we
don't want to know about your boyfriend
yep
we don't know that he had a big nut sack
and he would come and he would come on
my face and it was just amazing because
he tells guys that there's a lot of
[ __ ] creepy women man and guys will
sit through that [ __ ] wow i won't uh
i've had friends in colorado i had this
this chubby couple
she was beautiful but they would talk
[ __ ] in front of me that would drive me
crazy and i would tell them one day one
day i just said listen you come over
here i can't listen to that [ __ ] no what
are you talking about we trust each
other i don't want to hear that [ __ ]
who does though girls don't want to hear
it either i don't want to hear about i
mean i we all know everyone has a past
nobody wants to hear about it i don't
hear about all the girls you [ __ ] before
me and she would giggle
and he would giggle like an [ __ ] and
i remember one super bowl
her telling a story about anal
how she didn't like the guy but
she wanted to be cool or some [ __ ] so he
would only [ __ ] reign over here
so this went on for like a year even her
boyfriend her brothers didn't know
nothing but just
and he's giggling like yeah i still do
it with him from time to time in the
anal and she would hit him well like
these disgusting [ __ ] people
these disgusting [ __ ] people
oh my god i'm lucky you cleaned up your
act
you know the hip is still out there you
don't want to show up with scars and
coughing
i'm super queen all right i haven't had
sex this year only once this whole year
whatever i'm on a cleanse
really yeah for real i worry about you i
can't have it
i really haven't you take that little
sativa you don't take the light off i'm
gonna take this i'll take this off with
you thank you you're thinking where are
your dates coming up you got any road
damage oh actually i'm here for the next
like six weeks i'm at the comedy store
this week if you happen to be in town
thursday and saturday but i'm going to
alaska in july i'm taking red band we're
going to go do shows up there and then
uh what's the name of the club
charlie's
i think that's it that's it yeah yeah i
went there last year it was so fun what
do you think i had the best time i had
when they put you up in the condo it was
a hotel
like a cool downtown yeah they they used
to put you up in the condo oh my gosh no
condo no condo no no
it was fun actually i met the harlem
globetrotters because they were in town
they loved you it was so fun i got to
shoot hoops that's part of their thing
hoops yeah yeah
yeah they would have [ __ ] passed you
around that bus thank you joey and
[ __ ] they're a family-friendly
organization yeah sure until you're
sucking that dick and eight of them are
hitting you in the head with their
basketball dicks
uh but uh i will say i just put up a new
website with a bunch of cool merch on it
and my podcast is doing really well
partly thanks to you so thanks to you i
love you to death you just uh
i always you know you inspire me when i
see you out there banging it out every
night thank you you're not looking for a
handout you know you're not blowing guys
at the comedy store so
i'm very proud of you that's why you got
my respects i love you thank you what's
going on with you lee what are you
feeling tonight i hear noises i hear
go pee hurry up
what are you feeling lee
[Music]
i'm feeling pretty high i'm gonna look
out good see i take care of you you're
telling me you're training you ain't
[ __ ] training you don't train me
until you're with uncle joey but anyway
let me talk to you people real quick uh
you know i try them all
but between you and i lyft has always
been the best service i gave lee
my lift code he loves it he had a bad
experience with all the other guys it
doesn't really matter
uh
you know
it's just a good company to work for and
they do a lot of great things
for their drivers that uh i could see
that they really
they care
you know when you drive for a right the
right ride sharing app every trip can
feel like a walk in the park with lift
you can pick your own hours and work
when you want
lyft can make driving the best job in
the world
lyft is the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
lyft believes that being a ride-sharing
driver should be fun if you're having a
good time so are the passengers you're
smiling you're giggling you got bottles
of water for them you got little mints
for them people like all this stuff and
if you're choosing the right sharing
company to drive for
go for the company that treats you
better and that's lyft
only
liftoff is app tipping when you drive
for lift you keep 100 of the tips
drivers have been paid over 150 million
dollars in
tips since the feature was introduced
express pay lets drivers get paid almost
instantly instead of waiting for weeks
lift has been taken lyft has taken the
guesswork out of pickups
the new amp device uses
color coded to help passengers
find their drivers you can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips
so want to make more money drive more
it's never been easier to give yourself
a raise it's plain and simple it's a
simple formula happy drivers mean happy
passengers maybe that's why nine out of
ten lyft drivers get a perfect five-star
rating so do me a favor you're sitting
there broke you're in between careers
you don't really know what you want to
do you still got to pay for the bills
guy you still got to put money away for
the future and you still got to make
things happen on your own you want to
start that ban you want to do this you
want to do that number thing you got to
do is make paper do me a favor
get a job go to lyft.com
joey today
and you can get a 500
driver bonus i mean limited time only
terms apply but you're just sitting
there go do something with your life go
justify your existence go to lyft.com
joey again that's lift.com
joey why sit there like a bump on a log
when you could be making extra money
meeting people expressing yourself and
getting fresh air you go to the airport
you go here you go there plus you're
with the best company out there go to
lyft.com
joey
right right now right lyft.com
joey again
lyft.com slash joey
number two
in fact we're gonna make sure kate gets
one of these
uh bidets are back
all right you walk around with that
stinky [ __ ]
you scratch your balls at work you're
like why is this happening to me
why do my fingernails stink why are they
turning yellow
why the other one's clear but these ones
are turning yellow something about the
four questions for passover listen dog
it doesn't really matter what it sounds
like
the only thing you should be excited
about is that bidets are back okay you
don't got to walk around with rusty ass
or non-confident about how your nut sack
stinks or whatever
and you're asking me what's what's a
bidet joey it's a portable bidet that
you put onto your toilet and after you
do your little business you put the
water on and it sprinkles your [ __ ]
clean plain and simple if you get the
distance it can hit your nut sack you
can also dip your little clam in there
you can also dip your helmet in there if
you listen let's just say you can make
it work things get bad you can take the
water and throw it in your face and wake
up in the morning
go to hellotushy
dot com right now
slash hit him lee charge boom and get 10
off you get a 60 day money back
guarantee but listen you're going to
[ __ ] love it everybody's happy i'm
happy this is i sit sometimes i don't
even take a [ __ ] i walk by i look at it
i turn the water on and i just sit there
for eight nine minutes
and let my life will flash before me
that could be my last day
let me get the party started right go to
hellotushy.com right now and press the
code word church boom ten percent off
your order this is money people why have
a stinky ass oh ladies you know you
[ __ ] stinks like [ __ ] death
you get a little bar of soap you let
that little water twinkle in your monkey
your tip top magoo you understand me
mother's day coming you even look at
your mother and you go what's my
mother's ass smell like boom nope take
the guess work out go to hellotushy.com
right now press in
church boom 10 off mother's day and i
know you looked at your grandfather and
said that [ __ ] looks like that
all he eats is [ __ ] applesauce he got
no teeth
his [ __ ] has the [ __ ] allure of
something that's about to get hit by a
train but it don't matter his days are
settled hellotushy.com right now slash
church boom ten percent off i want to
give love to lyft
i also lift what is it delete lyft.com
slash joe lip.com want to give them some
love all sort of my main people on it
pushing out the supplements you
understand me alpha brain money back
guaranteed
shroom tech sport will change your
[ __ ] life go to honor.com and press
in church boom bam 10 off [ __ ]
see you guys wednesday night i want to
thank my girl k quigley don't forget to
follow on twitter
facebook from time to time she's [ __ ]
tremendous thank
love you guys love you
oh my god
[Music]
that was you dude
you